let's get it red beanie boys anyone red
beanie boys
plant gang oh i was muted that whole
time how do i change
the game settings
you can do it when you yeah if you
customize the laptop or i think you can
kind of do some of it when you create
the room right
okay confirm eject's off yeah i want
uh what what are all the good settings i
haven't played this game in a bit kill
cooldown i think
25 is probably fair yeah and i
tend to like to add a couple of short
tasks to the default
yeah i would say one maybe two one
four right two one four two one yeah one
four that sounds good
yeah that seems to kill this since every
yeah i know a lot about this game do all
those things kill this in this medium
yeah that's fine uh no short do short
oh yeah uh imposter vision 1.5
tasks off good point
who's [ __ ] hacking into the matrix
right now
[Laughter]
hello sorry i'm late hey eddie hello
eddie
i'm going to change the voting time to
90 seconds
yeah nice egg alana oh
yes oh i have i have a request
emergency meetings one emergency
cooldown 15 15
voting time 90 player speed one crewmate
vision one
imposter vision 1.5 25 second cooldown
i think player speed yeah 1.25
uh visual test off and then it goes
2-1-4 for a common long and short
i would like everybody to wear a
birthday hat oh
wow man i would like
i would like everybody to wear a
birthday hat in the game even though
if you increase the amount that you're
sending all of us via paypal
like this by how much different ones
what are you doing
double it
mark you can't do that what do you mean
there we go
customization oh i don't do
it's my birthday mark that's really good
you guys wear business parts norris come
on
for the first time in my life i have to
turn mark up
yeah i had to as well yeah same oh sorry
you're real okay can you go just give us
some levels that much
uh hey what is this i don't want to put
on a hat
yeah uh quite as many times like a lot
yeah i just put him on my knife
he doesn't want hat hair i might have a
200 over here yeah okay i might do that
mark you would look so pretty
all right i think we're all here anyone
else have a uh
a birthday drink i think it might
yeah i'm liking it nice nice i'm
starting the game thank you all for
coming to my wonderful birthday back
happy birthday let's go let's kill each
other
[Music]
this is the loudest discord call i've
ever been in hell yeah brother
good luck kill me
[ __ ] how did this happen immediately
this is the the absolute worst bro this
is the
this this is some [ __ ] i hate it a lot
okay well let's just hang out together
shall we you know if we just go places
together
why are we all walking so fast
oh we could okay yeah go go go go go go
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i should have done it i
should have done it i missed it i just
hit the button wrong
the speed of the walks is stressing me
out uh but i'm like what if we just like
hang out together you know then we can
maybe make some cool stuff happen
come in here pretend to do damn it
wow that was quick the walk speed is so
fast
i feel like his heart's not in it what
are you doing in cafeteria huh
i went up to do the trash can trevor
you're
orange right yeah okay um so i was in
admin i saw
uh mark stop in the hallway walk down i
just walked down and trevor you were at
the task and i didn't even see the body
i got the
thing to click report and you were
standing right wherever that was
was i yeah
that's all i saw of anybody in that
direction but i walked down
was that when the lights were out or
when they came back on when they were
out there i guess
did they come back on right before it
ended i think for the record
chris and i were in electrical fixing
lights i was also an electrical
i'm not accusing trevor i'm just saying
i saw mark stop there you shouldn't be
accusing me because
you were doing a task i also saw so
somebody could have swiped somebody
i'm not excusing this is definitely a
revenge kill for not wanting to put on a
hat
you gotta come here you had it coming i
can tell you what i do
motive if you want if you want me to
tell you where i was at and what i did
i'll i'll
happily let you know all right
did anybody see anyone around storage or
was around trevor at all trevor you see
anybody around there
i don't remember dude what is this
bizarre defense that you have just doing
my wires man trying to enjoy my day oh
wait wires
that's the tell he was at he was
standing at the wires whenever oh okay
yeah solid he's like i'll teach you to
wear [ __ ] birthday hats
voting eddie right out of the gate oh
chris what
wait chris what the [ __ ]
okay i don't want to do it like i can't
throw games
i know that when you're the imposter you
still have to play the video game
but it makes me feel sick
you know
i [ __ ] hate it bro i hate it nobody
really saw us go through here so i
probably could kill brian
um but i'm worried that somebody else
will come back out so
that just seemed too risky i just get so
nervous you know i just get
so [ __ ] nervous okay
okay okay okay
i should just move probably away i think
actually i probably should have just
kept going my voice is really deep today
how has this happened i don't understand
at all
just hang out wait for the timer
okay um it is all right it is
lower left side reactor
and wait hold on two bodies there are
two blocks
oh [ __ ] okay okay so i was
uh there's another body which uh i
literally saw after the emergency was
called
oh what were you doing yeah bloody where
were you yeah
i was in uh what is it top right
navigation yes and the birthday boy was
there too
again again
again and as i finished the task i saw
the corpse the meeting was called
and uh ethan is not dead so anyway
where you have to match up the arrow
thing and then
right as i exited from that it said
report and then the body
the other body was found this is real
life gamers
you can vote me out if you want but i
actually did not see the body
because it was hidden behind the chair
and nav that dude and i didn't
i didn't see it right away in the chair
that's convenient you know how did you
know it was hidden behind the chair
i'm just assuming it was not in the
chair ethan
ethan you can vote me if you want vote
me if you want
everybody's talking to a birthday boy
because he's bad at speaking
wait wait i i believe ethan a little bit
because he does have
horrible adhd i mostly just don't want
to vote for him because it's his
birthday but that [ __ ] sucks
i do actually think we should skip i
just got on board yeah i got it okay i
got it okay
you don't put on seven
all right so it's probably ethan yes
that's on ethan
well well well
it just makes me sick i get so nervous
that i wanna die
i [ __ ] hate it i don't wanna kill
ethan we gotta leave him alive
i'm just gonna stand here and pretend to
do this though and not kill ethan
because that task only takes like a
second right so we just [ __ ] do that
and then we peace out or i could
i could have killed chris there no
there's too many of them over that side
of the map
which does mean they're all accounted
for to be fair
oh we should sabotage more that's too i
can't click it now because it's too
obvious that i was just [ __ ] standing
there
okay do this one and then we'll do a
little
electrical
we go to just you know disrupt the pack
is really the plan
oh [ __ ]
i don't know what to do everyone's so
fast
i would like to kill you okay cool
okay cool okay cool
okay ethan is still alive just for note
where it was in a hallway on a hallway i
was on my way to the right side
and uh yeah it was just laying there
is the second body you came across right
bloody mm-hmm
yeah seems like sam is trying to frame
me
i don't know about that i passed alana
and uh yeah then it was on the left i
think yeah
yeah you were on that i was on the left
side bloody brian
and paladab this round i have not seen
ethanol shovel
i was on the left i did not see ethan at
all ryan
at the end also not seen maybe i saw you
once even brian where were you at
i was i was uh fixing lights and then i
went to the left and that's when the
body got reported so i'm in lower left
reactor right now
did you sabotage lights brian or was
that something oh dude yeah that was
like the first thing i did i'm so glad
that i fixed it afterwards
okay i was on i went on the cams for a
little while and then i went in reactor
and that's how i knew brian was there
yeah i think i've seen brian in every
spot where her body has been killed
coming back to me this time he wasn't
but i don't know about the other time
okay
so here's what i was literally just
telling my chat i was like i can
vouch for amber unless she's marinating
me very hard right now
and now i'm believing that dating vane
marinating
you yeah
i feel like that's probably good that's
probably good we probably did a good
thing i think that was good
i think we had to we should we had to
vote there and that was the worst
we had to we just one more okay so
amber all right bye i've really gotten
away with this
okay
and i i guess we'll go down here
and then just sort of we just need to
well we need to kill two more right
right i think it's two let me just
[ __ ] oh my god
i think that i should just go for it
actually
is the thing um
and like not even worried about being
caught at this point because we could
get the win
if even if i get caught as long as we
don't both get caught
right hey
look i will not even buy
neither of you are on my radar that was
so tidy oh my god
i was thinking about shelby at the very
end of the round before i got booted off
the ship and i was like
shelby i've known shelby for a very long
time and shelby's voice sounds weird
right now so much
she's been killing people around the
ship don't stick it around
oh that was great that was it was good
stuff yeah it was really tidy great
watch shelby
great work so proud of us good job both
of you
neither of you
i'm shaking so much after that one that
like i can't really hold things properly
i don't know why
but i'm very uh it's just
jesus christ this is like hard to press
keys
why did that get me so bad maybe it's
because it's people i don't know
i'm not sure but oh boy rock me to my
core
oh very clean work um even though with
the times where i think that i did
stuff that was dumb it turns out that it
was not dumb
um i have gotten a lot better at being
imposter in this game
um but here's my thing you guys i'm a
person who doesn't like lying so i still
just
don't lie i just don't lie i just well i
mean i have actually
destroyed andrea last night by flying
for italy but generally i just go
here's where i was and what i was doing
here is who i saw nearby
um because i'm not a not a good liar i'm
shaking so much
are you guys going to react about that
please stop shaking
why okay okay okay okay
just trying to stay alive
just trying to not die
i think mark's okay we've been in each
other's vicinity quite a bit
thank you you're right i do need deep
breaths
[ __ ] i think trevor might kill me
just thank you oh my god
where do i need to go also right here i
don't think i want to be with any of
these [ __ ] because one of you is
faking
this is how i die but there's a lot of
people nearby you'd be taking a risk
you would be taking a [ __ ] risk okay
how is nobody dead this doesn't make any
sense
damn wait oh okay
okay so yeah ethan's body is an o2
um yeah i don't actually think it's
enough
for an accusation because it seems like
we pinched that body at the same time
walking up to it
um i don't uh
[ __ ] because yeah we walked up at the
same time i didn't see anybody walking
away from the body but i walked out so
they must have vented
where were you i was uh failing admin
cards bad timing you guys it was bad
timing so did you see
did you because alana was in the in the
hallway right next to us and now she's
dead like
i don't understand how that makes any
sense i i literally was in my tasks so i
did not see that body
chris where were you guys in nav or
admin rather admin and
a lot of what was in admin i was an
admin too
yeah wait did you see the body bloody no
i was doing my task i saw these people
like
bottom right corner you ain't doing card
swipe
out is always shoveling
[Laughter]
no i was confused i was like where's my
next task at okay
eddie's uh so then trevor you see
anything that round all right i've saw
nothing i will say this
i will say this i've been getting my
card swipes on the first try
every time i don't know i promise that's
nice
okay well i'm not a natural gamer like
you um
i'm just saying suspicious i don't know
it's suspicious
[Music]
listen stream snipe me quick drop by my
chat they're all making fun of me
no self promo please
sub to chris melberger
i want to be a ghost and talk to eve but
everybody's just on mute
we could talk in dead chat you guys
could use dead chat and just type to
each other
okay
okay that was fast yeah it's fast as
hell whoa what the hell
i found mark at the top of electrical
okay uh nav wires and looped back around
to
admin to do card swipe which i didn't
get to do again
wait uh really quick so shelby there was
nobody in electrical when you walked in
there because i saw you walk up
yeah i walked in he was at the very top
there's no one else in there i'm
thinking they probably vented in
okay so who's in med bay i still don't
know where the vents lead so
i'm no help here i'm sorry okay
yeah uh chris where are you at
i was in storage and uh that's it
because the round was pretty quick
okay who's in admin with me
i was an admin with you okay eddie where
were you then
i was shelby saw me walking across like
i was at the bottom end going through
storage and then electrical and then
she'll be hooked up into electrical
and then found the body there um i
i don't by what you're saying i don't
think it was a kill an immediate
self-report cause you just walked in
there so that'd be something
some quick [ __ ] but um
who did it though i feel like i just
don't know anything that's right yeah i
don't think we knew enough to vote
on something yeah you died this round
was it alana or mark
fun i think our speed's too fast we're
not
able to locate each other yeah we have
to vote next round
sometimes it do be like that
i'm dead we're not gonna finish our
tasks
anyway so i don't feel a need to do them
oh look at eve's little dead guy
look at this little dead friend i'm just
gonna do the wires
and then generally not do them unless
they get closer to doing their tasks
hi eve hello oh what are you doing
traveling what you doing trevor
trevor what's the plan what's his plan
buddy buddy you just stand there
oh whoo how did he do that
sorry holy hello
how that happened i missed something i
just saw trevor uh
self-report on cam oh wait self-report
no wait i was i literally where was the
body
i came out from doing the the lee thing
and they come back out and then
their body was playing in that hallway
that's crazy
there's no way like how did you see me
kill them because i didn't kill them i
walked up to them
so here i didn't see you uh and be
honest guys i didn't see the kill but
you like kind of like we're walking
around it and then you're like i should
probably
report this i walked right into it what
do you mean there was no like
delay or stutter okay
just as someone who's played with both
of you a little bit
uh chris is incredibly quiet this round
but i can but i can also see trevor
pulling a self-report move because he's
very good at playing victim
i think i'd be inspired chris christie
did you you didn't see him get the kill
i didn't see him get the kill but i did
see him like on the body and then
wait a while to report it could have
been ping it's been such a while since i
played this game you can't knock me on
like reaction time
you gotta drag the mouse all the way to
the bottom of the corner
we have to vote
away i don't it was the top uh
out of the fourth game we have 14
seconds we have to vote on something
with trevor and then we vote for chris
okay
okay i'm gonna vote for chris okay
sorry sorry bud sorry bud sorry
amber why'd you vote for eddie that is
crazy every
okay my gosh spicy [ __ ]
um i guess i'll do a test but i mostly
just want to see murderer
you know
the little dead companions they leave
behind are always so sad
oh man yeah um so i like wasn't positive
who
i'm like i know most of these people but
don't necessarily know the names they're
calling each other um
like i i didn't know modest cube's real
name uh so i'm but i can't change it in
discord so sorry if that's confusing to
any of you who don't
know who these people are um i do not
have ability to change
anything
i'm just doing my tasks anyway what's
wrong with me why am i this kind of
person
i wanted the entertainment why am i
doing this
i hate myself wait is it a swipey swipe
is that what i had to do no that's a
mapping map the med bay i have to go get
this scan
what's mock doing why is he hanging out
down there is there someone in there
okay what up amber's body is at o2
we were right on trev so let's go pat's
on back
because there's four left so there's
only one imposter left right uh
i i was so i was on cams the whole time
because i've been done with tasks since
last round
i saw you i came in to do it yeah i
watched you do task at reactor while
uh o2 went off so
uh the emergency started and i went to
the left side instead because it was my
last
last task and now i'm done uh
but yeah i don't know what happened over
there yeah he's got tasks
left i have like two tasks left okay
i'm gonna be honest um i was on my way
to o2 i passed
amber uh i saw her last near uh like the
left reactor sign of things like around
that area engine so this and i saw
bloody around there too so this could
either be that
or a self report from eddie because i
think brian's probably good
i saw when i was down in storage i was
stopping into electrical to do a task
and i saw bloody go
right after i did and i took the hook
like down
to the right and up to o2 and that's
where i found the body
so i don't know i had a task storage
to refuel okay so yeah
i did that and then i went to the left
ryan chris what are you doing you know
tesla
i have no tasks
did you see me dancing on cams i did see
you dancing on camera
a little bit weirded out by it but uh
i've never had any questions in this
game at all
yeah yeah we we can win on task people
are fast
i have a few nuts though oh boy
daddy and teddy doesn't a few would be
everybody right no i just too i think
brian's
two kills i think if i'm dead guys that
he got me
it's gonna be tough i mean he could have
just voted someone out at the last
second there
and it like you would have just had to
murder someone before he got to them
um okay oh maybe it is on me
[Music]
i i had the lost task and didn't realize
chris what actually happened that was so
unfortunate is
i got that kill in nav and trevor just
happened to walk on it
and so it was like i was getting away
from it completely and i accidentally
implicated trevor as the imposter for no
right oh that sounds
good it's so funny yeah
dude trevor i didn't even know what to
say i was like [ __ ] if i vouch for him
too hard like it's god damn
yeah wait so killers were eddie and
chris that round it was me and trevor
no trevor trevor so that's why we were
right when we got him so funny to watch
you getting done for a thing you didn't
do though i was like well trevor killed
me
but trevor was serious that he didn't
walk up to it
uh chris what did you use what did you
say i should turn down
is there a thing that you said that i
should turn down i think for the player
speed is a bit too high because i feel
like we're not able to keep track of
where we are but maybe that's just me
ethan your child is clipped by the like
oh so ethan one day
yeah yeah did you get
a lot of sugar your child yeah 120 oh
for voting time
yeah boarding time yeah 120 okay better
should i turn down in player speed or no
whatever you want doesn't matter to me
guys speed
okay okay okay yeah we got a dub that's
fun
yeah it was my task i was dead and i was
like mostly ghosting around and then i
was like oh
it might be mine and finished it while
it goes might be me
okay
okay ready to stay alive
let's do it i hate this one because i
often press x
long before i need to and i really get
screwed
not this time sun completed it
okay okay why are you walking away
trouble
oh no that was my dad he was walking in
the right direction actually
i should have gone to reactor but didn't
because i thought for some reason my
brain was like it's the 102 that's the
first one that counts down so they
always stop with that one
alas they did not
it's always a mark oh we got two deaths
oh yeah
oh [ __ ] too all right yeah just can't
get a game in
i went over to nab to do tasks and then
looped down through shields and storage
and was uh up in electrical where i
found the body
and was there no one else in there there
was no one else in there
i know who the killer is but i'm not
going to say it yet what what yeah what
seems like a dumb place that's kind of
weird
i feel like we should know it's his
birthday that's unbelievable
no what the hell why am i the killer
birthday chris let's fight him out
[Laughter]
wait hold on chris i want to hear your
eyes yeah i kind of i
kind of am weird about that
doing our thing i left because the um
reactor went off
okay and then as i walked up to reactor
ethan
stuck around electrical and i was like
in my brain
yo if uh mark's dead it's ethan if mark
said his teeth and then sure enough it's
mark's [ __ ] blue
ham slice also chris's story makes sense
because right after reactor i headed
toward electrical and chris was going
right back to do whatever task he was
doing so that is a pretty credible story
you go back to because brian when did
you
when did you find bloody did you see
chris there i i didn't
at what point i was like
i i didn't find the second body i only
found that one body
ethan the problem we're having here is
that at no point have you actually
defended yourself you just asked
other people questions to be fair this
is
sort of how he defends himself he's just
like
that doesn't why is it me you're like
well no that's not how it works in court
bro
you got to tell us well listen ethan
what were you what are we voting
well it's my birthday
why am i voting
okay whoever just voted for chris just
keep that in mind
i think chris was asking people to vote
for him i didn't vote
[Music]
hey visual tops are on please look
shelby
look at me shooting thing do you see it
thank you she saw it i'm good i'm good i
have been cleared
yes yes not going to die
at the hands of the court
what are you doing amber what [ __ ] is
this oh
doing a task it's fine i was like what
behavior is this
ryan
i think somebody's probably gonna die
here
everyone's alive okay i just got
suspicious of the situation
everyone running into that room all at
once just
i don't know i'm never right about that
for the record i'm never right about
like being like somebody's probably dead
in that room
okay interesting chris
is dead wait hold on alana what was that
about us
like 30 seconds ago you were walking the
opposite direction you seem to follow me
up the hallway
i came back because i i literally had
the thought of thinking that somebody
was going to be dead in that room i
believe it was amber there and when
brian walked up the hallway i was like i
think am is going to be dead so i
doubled back and then i was like oh no
it's fine
so then i left um uh
uh the only time i saw amber we were all
in
nav i could be completely misremembering
which is chris dead on the ground
[Music]
oh wait hold up brian you came in la uh
after eddie didn't you into navigation
where
did you make a little stop in o2 baby
shots no what i did was i started off at
the beginning of the round i went right
all the way to nav
i went back down for the record my chat
is telling me i mean admin and not r2
my memories oh admin i'm talking about
yeah no i literally just came back to
nav because i forgot to do a task in
there
where does the vent and admin lead to um
we're just meeting but i feel like you
self-reported this i'm not a i don't
think we should vote
hang on hang on one thing um uh uh
visual tasks on
i don't know no [ __ ] i don't think
because i literally while i was shooting
the asteroids i was like please shelby
please please please see me do it
because i was shooting the asteroids
right below you
i i don't think we should vote alana
because there's nothing there's nothing
enough i just
even this reasoning feels very
believable 100 not me
uh who are the other people who voted
for uh
what was eddie i voted for i voted for
chris only because he literally yelled
brian's vote for me and i went
why
[Music]
those are the two of you that could have
killed me and didn't this time but
otherwise
yeah i'm i'm good on amber because she
could have killed me and now probably
i just because i'm really just doing it
because you voted for chris because i
saw you
i i don't really know we had to vote for
someone
[Music]
okay good luck everybody oh god
are you serious oh my gosh
i don't really want to know what the
reasoning was for that
literally because because i was like i
bet you money that you voted
for me on a guess no mine was literally
because because of what i said the
minute that someone is like hey
vote for me i feel like an actual
crewmate would generally not do that and
you were the last one left who did it so
i was like if we have to work for
someone it's got to be you
that was big brain way to go
oh my god chris you called me out so
quick that i just didn't my date
my brain didn't know how to process it
and i was like oh no yeah i'm done
he wasn't gonna i think
holy [ __ ] no that was amazing i saw mark
chilling and i was like
if if he's dead it's ethan 100 and it
was yeah i'm
sorry for killing you right i don't know
has mark gotten to play the game yeah
don't kill me just let him live look i
don't holy [ __ ]
you don't want to
you just like to do let's go again let's
see who
gets the murder knife god i had so much
reason to be kicked out
i didn't get to do that longer
okay okay okay okay
i usually in these kind of games uh when
my friends get used to it i'm pretty
good at sleuthing okay i can be super
wrong
but generally like pretty good at
sleuthing ryan
um so if i play games like this like a
mafia or whatever
mark people start killing me first
whenever i
keep getting to play with new groups of
people i don't have to worry about that
because they don't know that i can do it
yet
okay um
but that one was a risk it's just my i
was like who did they vote for one of
them's dead there's only one left that's
got some [ __ ]
please don't kill me don't kill me if
you boy do not kill me
no we are all alive okay
well if i'm in here actually i should
just do the talk
what why am i hearing my name right now
well well hello
let him talk hey maybe i saw some maybe
i didn't
you know oh wow interesting whoa
you know all right 50 50. i feel like
you did yeah
listen hey 50. i like that in a 50 subs
you know and maybe i'll talk
50 subs very very essential very
important
could be incriminating okay jesus
please gonna run out of time
oh you know my eyes aren't very good you
know it's real foggy
oh my god i
saw i didn't clear up my vision mark and
i were both in electrical
putting out the lights and the lights
came on and there was a dead body up
there and eddie was walking down
the lights he just said he put the
lights out they're putting the lights
putting the lights on i literally i
followed ethan the whole way there we
were together the whole time
if he showed up into electrical and
there was a dead body it was not ethan
okay but alana you saw me dip in and
then dip out and watch you guys fix the
lights and leave right i did see that
yes
so you two seemed to be the last in
electrical and ethan started by saying
my name and accusing me when i never
went to the top of electrical once
i dip my my guy in to make sure nobody
was getting killed doing the lights
that is right even ethan and when it
started ethan said
eddie no seems like you didn't do that
very well did you i think what happened
here is that ethan misunderstood but i
promised you i walked the hallway
with ethan he was next to me and then
right and i saw i saw mark fixing the
lights and i saw you and ethan standing
there and i was just making sure no one
was dying and i walked away so
wait mom where was the body i will say
eddie literally he was fine all right i
did get 50 subs
the body
no anyway okay cool it had to have been
in the bathroom i'm so glad that
happened
eddie and i were alone shields at one
point and he easily could have killed me
at the beginning of the round
i don't even need a i didn't go to the
top of electric it's 100
not eddie because it would also be super
weird to come in and then leave it
it is not eddie eddie is good it was
also definitely not ethan i promise
[Music]
not dead yet so it's probably him okay
okay yep i'm so bad
remembering things is my main problem oh
my god this is too many people
um and i need to do a better job of that
because it really screws the game up
sometimes
look at me go and i forget people's
names
and it's you know it's a real event that
occurs
my short-term memory is atrocious
because i have a chronic illness
that pertains to memory loss short term
all right i'm someone's gonna be [ __ ]
dead in here again and i'm gonna get
blamed no no okay we're doing all right
okay it's done is anybody dead in here
nope
no i have to do this though travis
trevor please i trust shelby i think i
don't remember who i trust from this
round or the last round either
jesus christ oh
oh
i'm making some moves over there a
reactor let's go
what
all right lads okie dokie i have a
question i have a question
at the very end before the body was
reported did anybody see
anybody in electrical was anybody in
electrical with anybody
[Music]
he was sprinting i walked in the storage
and i saw you start running away and i
was walking to the bottom
were you guys at the bottom or the top
of electrical
i wasn't in electrical no the people
that were locked okay
wait you were in electrical when the
lights went out me
no eddie eddie and chris were both
lights yeah no i fixed the lights
someone else walked in yeah when we were
locked in
toward the end of the round i'm just
saying i saw you both standing at lights
not doing them until lana walked in
and then they got like
the flip game where we were not fixing
it by trying to fix it together
ethan what is the point of your
questions the point of my question
is because med bay was closed and i went
past it and i was like ooh that's a
little suspicious i waited for it to
open up
i went in and brian was dead and so if
anybody was in the top of electrical
near the end of the round
they probably vented from okay
to electrical so all of the people who
were locked in
um electrical left i went up to the left
to reactor and then shelby and trevor i
saw stop outside the door and then go
right
yes yeah and my uh doors opened i walked
past you into storage and trevor is
claiming
that i was chasing him and i was just
going to explore it
you walk faster
i mean the door by lower engine when
that oh gosh you're leaving
i was was anyone near uh reactor or like
that hallway at all
i was in reactor just now i just was i
was just about to go one on the thing
and then the thing happened and i was
i'm sorry
ethan from finding these bodies and
accusing right away
it's not
[Music]
[Laughter]
what have you been up to bud wow doing
tasks
uh convenient conveniences
yeah sounds about right
so this one's a bit slower we could
probably just get our [ __ ] tasks done
they already know i have to just come
back here
get this done
[Music]
i can count to ten little-known facts
okay i have to go to med-bay
uh spicy boy
oh god wow
i don't know where that was oh you
recorded it
yeah shelby it was right at our feet me
you and ethan i believe
just walked down into that so who was
coming from
around nav and maybe going down or just
chris i thought on the way out he was
leaving yeah i was going to go fix it
yeah no i saw chris leave nav and go up
and then i walked down into it so it
would have to be somebody hooking from
the bottom and getting a kill
i came from up i came from o2 and i was
going over to nav
was there no one from bottom i couldn't
see bottom because of the
the like the visibility for it uh
like i walked in it was the hallway
where it just started to peak i saw a
report and clicked immediately
i don't think it's i don't think it's uh
ethan cause he just
i don't my stress is removed from ethan
because he he me
him and shelby walked down into that
okay so i went to immediately do the
toss that was disrupted for me last time
in reactor and then ended up in med bay
it was called when i
just stood on the thing uh which
to me means people not accounted for our
bloody mark and chris
what were you guys doing i was i was uh
chris was
back up uh through calf i was going that
way but then i saw everyone
yeah shelby you and ethan were coming
you were coming from oh
to the cafeteria okay you were coming
from the top and ethan you were coming
from
too right i'm a little suspended but
only because he was i was coming from
other
because we walked in the same spot at
the same time yeah
okay um all right
never mind what now come on what's that
what are you doing oh
i was uh given a list of things to do
and i was doing them from top to bottom
he's making himself so suspicious that i
feel like it can't be him
but this is what mark does
[Music]
this is what you do you go i'm doing
things and then people are like well
what are you doing you're like i
think well nobody's asked me about
anything and
who
no i was miles away that's weird
[Music]
i i killed nobody i just did my reacting
task
i was they said they saw him going up so
i was like what if we do this
and i bet you i get killed by him now
she said hello you gotta just vote for
someone man okay
a very small party hat man
okay okay okay okay okay we actually are
getting pretty close to finishing our
tasks like on a consistent basis
uh we could we could do we could do this
we could do this
somebody is on security cameras
we might legitimately finish our [ __ ]
toss i just have one more
bro
um no you didn't i saw you through
security though
i just saw bloody kill ethan on his
birthday
i would never do that i didn't know what
did you just say
did you just say you saw him on cams yep
no you didn't i was on camps
i
no don't try to frame me did you try and
did you leave wires go on cams and go
back to wires
what wires you okay no
what i saw you outside security on wires
because i've been on the cams the whole
time until the lights went out so i left
and that came back i saw you security
and then i literally stole blood still
even so
either oh my god
so i left i turned the lights back on
she was when i get got back
she was still on wire panel at cam so i
don't know
i trust shelby and mark as well because
i saw both i could have been blamed
so easily one of you could have killed
the other and if shelby you were in
security i just saw you killing you
i don't know i feel like i believe him
it's crazy
it's chris and uh shelby
[Music]
oh
when i guessed chris i cannot believe i
was right
for so long
you did absolutely play third imposter
there oh my god i totally thought that
it was chris and you at the end
yeah chris i didn't know the math still
i still don't know all the math for the
game so when you said i lied
i'm like is chris doing a ballsy move
where he's just gonna like have both of
us be
known for the last i killed ethan and i
saw us on camp so i literally waited
until
whoever i knew was on cams to come over
and i was like it's bloody i had to lie
immediately
that was crazy whatever i actually
wasn't
the whole
i was like [ __ ] trevor's gonna think i'm
chasing him i actually wasn't trying to
kill him there
and the second time we did like a little
dance before he just came down and just
[ __ ] like punched me
that's crazy that was a good one
good luck have fun guys
okay easter let's put in some good work
for you but you're a pastor again and
you have work to do buddy
little iffy boy i could just kill bloody
right now
you know because people rarely go up the
top so if we just do that and then we
just [ __ ] bounce
med base not a good place to be though
okay okay okay okay okay everything's
fine everything's fine
i didn't mean to do that oh my god that
was literally an accident
i don't know why i pressed that i i
wanted to sabotage and now i'm scared
[ __ ]
this is awkward all right hello
trevor we gonna talk about this talk
about what
the body that i just found next to you
while you
what i was right there too oh there was
a body right up there
in the cafeteria yeah top right
what screen for us because we're on the
left side oh top right okay yeah we were
top left the cafeteria so why would
trevor have to do it
as soon as i got to the middle is when
like it got uh because i saw him in my
field of view and i saw the body then
okay yeah no i but i walked up with
trevor we both i had a wire i mean i
don't i can't vouch for 100 trevor but i
was uh
doing wires down in storage came up to
me yeah and i was like
that was what happened i would have
somehow went all the way to the right
killed and went all the way back
all right so it's either an uh an eddie
trevor special or something else about
it
orange or it's you oh it's chris it's
not me
you could pull me out i'm a big brain
okay i got the small stop chris
he's he's in the large is like a level
500 player in this game
it's hard to tell he's already had a
seat
wait so hold on chris why why would it
be trevor i'm sorry
so i walked into the cafeteria there was
a body and he was like right next to it
not doing anything about it maybe
maybe he just missed it i don't know but
i just saw it right next i did miss it
and it was top
rider center it was like top right like
next to the leaf uh where you throw the
leaves out
i was saying why would trevor be on your
screen though we were like to the okay i
guess maybe
when you walk in center you could have
come on but yeah i think that's the
point where he saw me
and it was so bad it was a bad
coincidence and what can i convince you
chris what
did did anyone see somebody like going
towards or near nav
i'm just kidding okay so do we we have
25 seconds left do we want to vote chris
or trevor do we want to skip
because you want to do a 50-50 yeah
shall we just babysit chris the next
round see where he goes what he does
guys i'm telling you i
on our
[Laughter]
i was just quoting ryan quoting us
[Music]
i could have gotten away with that is if
i had a just last second
voted for trevor i don't think they even
would have been mad at me
like i fully could have done that and
gotten away with it ah
this is the [ __ ] worst dude i don't
like killing people in
in um electrical because i so rarely
have a way out
[ __ ] why just let me i just don't want
to be imposter anymore
they [ __ ] hate it
okay well i could just kill eddie no
good thing i [ __ ] didn't do that holy
[ __ ]
movie okay so i
threw weapons i went down into o2 to do
some tasks and then outside of shields
there was a dead
trevor
i want everyone to remember how hard i
was just vouching that i thought trevor
wasn't the imposter
and trevor just got [ __ ] killed so um
super silly by the way because now that
sus goes out i was just with shelby
and who else was in the room with us
shelby i was walking out of electrical
and you two walked in it was okay yeah
okay
brian and chris both near o2 like around
in navigation i was babysitting chris a
little bit but not too much
uh so any of them could have gone down
to shields
and then come back up brian did you
see i didn't see anyone i literally only
went into o2 and i flushed some leaves
for the last one you didn't i
saw nobody i literally well i saw chris
but i didn't see anybody else
wait but that was my question did chris
go up or down oh no i
i have no idea i didn't i wasn't like i
just told trevor in a body i didn't
necessarily say it was him i just saw
him in
in the cafeteria with a body that's why
i was confused okay well okay
in the first round okay i do okay yeah
was walking in that way i don't think
voting chris would be smart here because
i don't think
he's got any evidence yet like i guess
like she's like yeah wait amber where
are
you
well i had a task in navigation so i was
like waiting for chris to walk down
there
just to see uh but eddie i have a
question um
why do you vouch so much for everyone
who's not really impressed
i don't think it's wise to vote people
out from like once
with with 20 seconds left i would like
to ask the age-old question
mark what were you doing
[Laughter]
10 seconds buddy
oh my god did you ever hear it we'll
never know now we'll get it we'll never
know jesus christ
okay if not your finest work probably
shouldn't have killed that particular
person is all i'm going to say
i could kill brian right now but i don't
feel like i want to do that either
we just you know pretend to look in the
cams and then we walk over and we
we commit crime like this is also a risk
but i'm just going to do that
he saw me leave [ __ ] i shouldn't have
left that body there though that's my
thing every time is i panic about where
i left a [ __ ] body you know
oh geez i need to get sighted i need
somebody to see me
could anybody please see me just
somebody see
me okay
i could do another one i could
but i i better do it gonna do it okay
we're just
it's just a [ __ ] rampage out here
please ethan please [ __ ]
um
[Music]
he was in the doorway to the reactor
okay okay how many people just died was
that three or was that two
um chris died and brian and
that was three think three oh yeah
that's okay because i know
possibly where chris died i had just
seen
chris quite recently uh
and the people who walked past me when i
was walking away from chris were
mark and ethan where sorry where was
chris
i don't know the rooms is the problem
the the one that's left
okay the farthest left room the one
sorry the farthest right room the
farther the one is the
furthest right the furthest right and
then i walked up it sounds like nav
and then to towards cafeteria through
weapons
yes and i saw you passing through
weapons
i the only people who headed in the
direction of of
chris from what i saw because i came
from the bottom were
mark and ethan amber was in admin wait
wait who are we actually reporting here
i believe oh
someone of us is a murderer
oh my god
figure him out because he's just a
[ __ ] dumbass all the time
i love you so
[Music]
you saw both shelby and alana saw mark
right
yes yeah do we want to vote vote mark
because there's only
look mark was there before you worry
then that's not
ever on the left side at all okay i'm
gonna vote mark because he's being
weird and i'm i cannot read him okay
okay
i am like jesus
what does that mean everyone said the
cross
is the game going to end did we win
yeah boy
[Music]
oh my god
yeah holy [ __ ] i killed a lot of people
i'm not
that ambitious crewmate on earth but i
will do nothing to defend myself that
was a really good game
i know i've never played with you so i
need to read
that's fine because i was just gonna ask
if you guys are down to switch to a
different map anyway
yeah yeah yeah yeah good oh my god
beautiful work just across the board
very happy
across the board that was just a great
job great job
i don't know you well enough so i when
you were telling me i just assumed you
thought
i was suss well i don't know you weren't
on my radar i don't think i have tells
generally people who don't know me are
wrong all the time also
um i'm just very nervous and i shake the
whole time i'm the imposter
look at my hands i'm shaking right now
voice a little bit i [ __ ]
that's that's the only tell if there's
anything is that i start shaking
it's the one you also said that you
didn't know the rooms correctly
no but that's true i don't i don't know
the rounds for everybody room correctly
no i totally didn't get nap right it's
gonna help
my impostor game and hurt my crewmate
game i don't know the other maps well
enough so i will be somewhere i think i
might actually
pull a map up just so that i can look at
it because that is which map
for the explanation i feel like that's
yeah yeah
um i'm going to go to the bathroom at
the same time right
yeah i think so yeah i gotta hit the
bathroom too i'll be right
chasing the first back of the game a lot
uh yeah a little bit
i knew i had a feeling you were like
going to try killing me first round but
i was like i don't know maybe he's not
but you were literally
falling yeah i was following you i
couldn't catch up to you so fast i'm
going to also pee real quick okay ew
i like this map i'm gonna go grab a beer
so do you uh you guys like fun dip
yo funded rules man you guys ever just
buy a pack of 100 and just eat the
sticks
what is one dip uh oh i
i was thinking the powder but yeah i
mean that that sounds good to
uh me the code code let me join
can someone explain to me what fun dip
is okay it's an american candy that's
literally just like this weird
sugar like stick made out of like
flavorless sugar
and you dip it tasty
sugar yeah and then you dip it into
basically pixie sticks
okay and it's horrible it's literally
sugar
immediately spicy
fairy bread spicy fairy bread
i've seen uh pictures of it
hundreds and thousands on bread and
butter
excuse me it's like it's like crack for
kids that's literally what it is
it's like sugary and like light right
yeah
well i mean have you ever had sprinkles
don't i think you guys call them
sprinkles
yeah what are those yeah but like the
round ones so like the little balls
hundreds and thousands okay you just
like dump a whole bunch of those
on bread and butter you call it
blueberry bread
australian slang is that that's
interesting and it tastes good
wait that sounds like a good mix of like
sweet and savory
and you're you're hating on fun savory
salty wait ethan do you want fun dip for
your birthday
i got like you guys mind if i i don't
remember what
fun dip is to be completely honest oh my
god oh my god so sad
well i don't know dude what's fun dip i
can't remember
you know candy
i don't want to explain it again dude
and you lick a little stick
and then you dip it in the powder off
the stick
i don't know if i can eat fun dip what
they don't have peanuts dude
wait are you getting ethan funded for
his birthday well i bought a bunch of
fun dip for myself and then
okay it's way too much it's literally
like enough to like
fill up like three grocery stores um
fill up them
they just they just seal the packages
with uh like they spread a little bit of
peanut butter and then they climb
they lick it and then they spread peanut
butter on it and then they seal it
closed
that makes sense
[Laughter]
who do we not have uh
mark no mark's here no he just never
talks
alana's not here holland is pooping
oh okay well wow dude come on dude
it's your birthday bathroom docks she's
taking an agb all right guys leave her
alone
hey gb yeah you've never heard kgb
no you've never heard that term before
no
no okay it stands for after grug
bug don't ask oh well yeah it's because
we don't
we don't call it grog here australian
slang is the best again i just said that
so an agb ask her how her agent b
went hey how are you doing here you go
nice oh so you'll have an agb after that
yes what is happening yeah i i love how
like normal this conversation is between
the two of you
but the rest of us are like this is new
australian
you know eat them and we're stupid make
a task bar update um after meetings
because that way it's it's
more fun for the imposters as well oh
wait are we all playing on beta right
now
no this is not good
also wait so chris yeah with that then
it doesn't show like we all get to see
it but it doesn't
oh it does not shoot during the middle
wait which
what thing do you want me to do uh
taskbar update
and make it uh meetings only i think or
something like that
yeah that way you can't like clock
someone for faking a task because the
bar didn't move
i don't know where do i do that what i
don't see that
um am i am i the leader no i'm not um
it's taskbar
updates it says under kill distance
uh all i have is visual tasks i think
that's one of the beta options
and either we all need to switch to beta
oh am i playing on beta
i'm playing on beta so i see it too
i don't i don't has
[Laughter]
i'm gonna start the game because i don't
have that okay that's fine
interesting
i mean general rule i would say actually
just don't look at the taskbar as proof
it kind of starts
okay
okay let's do it
oh yes sorry i just unmuted myself to
talk to them and discord before i'm
muting myself on the stream for the
round
apologies friends but yes i am aware
okay
this is going to seem sauce because i'm
standing here because i'm drinking my
smoothie
that's not ideal
okay okay okay
we can do this immediately that's fine
that's fine
cool i need to explain an agb to you
guys now
whoa chris i was i was standing by you
on med bay to just kind of confirm
and i feel like i confirmed that you're
real
there has been a more real has been a
killer or real as
in a crewmate i like that mark is
actually trying to talk and we're like
shut up
we're having a conversation yeah what do
you see i found
the body all right blood everywhere
yeah man tell us about it it's your time
it's your turn to shine sing the gospel
uh-huh body was bloody all right you're
bad bloody everywhere
you don't need power what else you got
for
concerning thing was that the skeleton
inside only had a single bone
okay any details
pretty suspicious yeah mark where was i
i was just making my rounds around the
base getting familiarized with the
location
thank you arthur mulkin i made it
someone has to kill him so we have a
chance
just the entrance of off the drop ship
the room to the immediate ride of that
right in the doorway saw it right on the
floor
such a shame wait to know top
the room like what is the right ship
that we walked out of
like mid okay is there like a big drill
looking thing
over there saw no drill the blood was
everywhere it's all i thought
we're running out of time all right so
we have no information
by the way did we um increase voting
time for market
[Laughter]
i'm confused i'm sorry i'm actually kind
of assassinated
yeah if mark's not an impostor i think
we had the right move the last
i'm gonna tell you guys just the fact
that brian just said
the fact that brian just said wait wait
are we skipping i'm confused is suss as
[ __ ]
crew mates don't say that [ __ ] i
literally am only
listening to mark ramsey
suicide i say that now
okay i don't trust any any crewmate who
on round one
goes what are we doing uh isn't
impossible
you know what you're [ __ ] doing round
one bro you know what you're [ __ ]
doing
you ain't doing [ __ ]
did i get caught up explaining what an
agv is sorry chat uh
it's an octagon which is basically a big
poopy tick when you have a hangover
um i guess because i was taking long
they assumed i was pooping but really i
got myself a smoothie
get out my way chris get out of my way
it's brian well he won't kill me now
right
right brian right no you don't no you
don't
i don't trust your [ __ ] ass at all
ryan stay away from me please just let
me do my tasks and not die
cause you anyone who ever says what are
we doing because all
[ __ ] crewmates should want to skip on
the first round every single [ __ ] one
of them
i don't [ __ ] trust brian at all
i could be wrong again that's the thing
is i say these things with such
confidence and then sometimes i'm like
oh oh it was oh it was rob that's it
and then it's just done you know
all righty then all right
no more um
where where did you come from after
before you did electrical i was down in
o2 the lights went out
i went up turned lights on and went back
down 02. it would do the tree
level and you didn't you didn't happen
to check out uh security at any point
right
oh i need the [ __ ] map what's this
map called how do i look on tv
oh i saw the light going okay it's this
one
uh so trevor died in cams they're on
cams and now they're dead oh i was not
in security then because i didn't see
the body
where
hold up sorry where was the body top
left in security
top left okay
on the bottom left at one point and then
she headed north but besides that i just
went back the middle of the map
who else was on the left who was on the
right so i know not in lab
i will say that uh brian did head into
the middle of the map
from the left after me just now um who
else did i see i saw
shelby and i saw one other person on the
top left
um did you notice when the cam lights
went out for how long he would have been
dead in there possibly
well because right before i saw because
uh
mark amber and i had gone top right and
then amber you're waiting for the
scanner i know and then i saw
shelby and trevor in top right and that
was the last i saw them
i went down to the investment room so i
saw those two
i saw shelby and trevor together last
year yeah i crossed
from lab i passed alana on the way into
o2 and that's where i've been correct
information i saw mark running out of
electrical all the way back to
laboratory and i don't know if he maybe
murdered somebody
alana was on the left correct everything
that i did was on the left and
right now i am in uh hang on i pulled
the map up i pulled the map up i'm in
the office and brian just walked in i'm
gonna be completely honest i pulled no
information from this
i checked like you were you were in
office too
i was you walked in behind me brian i
saw you on the left oh i walked by
okay got it all right oh i didn't vote
at the very end i got super scared that
you were gonna kill me
i think i couldn't tell if you were over
the ventilator that was my that was my
gamer
that was my gamer walk pro strat bro
okay i still think brian suss
who is a lovely person for the record
really lovely dude
uh it's not his fault that he is i
cannot do anything about that
i really love the guy uh no motorist
tendencies in real life
um why for some reason
i didn't even see him i didn't
ethan ethan ethan that's me dead ethan
okey-dokey so
this is all the information i have i was
over in o2
uh shelby and i both went in there
around the same time
i did the o2 canisters the lights went
out alana was also in there i could see
her
in my periphs if you will and then the
lights were still out
i went out of the o2 canister thing and
her body was somewhere over there the
report button just showed up i don't
actually know where it was shelby why
were you in uh o2 again weren't you
there last round i never finished the
tree because i stopped it to turn the
lights on before
but i finished that and i left i've been
in comms doing my upload i never went
towards lights this time because i'm
just still in the middle of the upload
okay but i'm just in uh
solid alibi kind of maybe i don't know
i don't know that's everything i got
mark what's that right there that it was
pretty big don't do
[Laughter]
did you i was walking around the middle
fearing for my life
i was circling the middle structure
brian said that he went to the middle of
the map has anyone ever asked
a question i was circling only
i
don't
i was literally about to activate the
task on the springboard bible brian for
sure
so i i don't think i was anywhere
knives
he's right if mock would tell his story
[Music]
this is only the second time i played
with amber so i didn't know that
son of a [ __ ] i don't remember who
killed me though was it shelby
i'm like i've already forgotten uh i can
do tasks we could do this
i'm like so caught up in being like
brian is a murderer that i literally
forgot who killed me um but i'm pretty
sure it was shelby and then i
immediately saw trevor
uh and then got confused but trevor is
also dead at his orange
[Music]
okay
[Music]
what are you doing brian you [ __ ]
murderer oh mark mark you're gonna die
in here
you're going to die [ __ ] no [ __ ]
leave he's going to kill you get out
i [ __ ] knew it i knew it eddie no
i knew it brian
oh my god
oh jesus christ right here we go gamers
mark is dead and i saw brian do it on
cam
brian yes so i went to go
bear with me brian i'm gonna need you to
stop and work your way out of this one
let me talk real quick so i was going
out of o2 trying to leave
or trying to enter in o2 from that long
tunnel mark and brian were at the door
i went into o2 did my task and then
brian mysteriously comes out of that
area
later and is now saying oh he saw me out
there no
all i was saying was i was vouching for
you because you were the only person
there beside you
huge right there and he voted i
literally saw him doing it
hold on okay quick vote real quick okay
that's super bizarre though chris did
you vote brian
absolutely yeah why didn't you ask more
because why didn't you ask me i said we
were voting so fast
i voted
i was literally hiding against the wall
trying to get away from him
why are you trying to get people to
strand snipe you probably also it's my
birthday
he's been literally sorted i voted brian
because ethan never sits on cams and so
if he says
someone on campus
that's right and the reason the reason
i'm on cams is that i'm
completely done with my tasks oh i think
this map
this is this will be it right it brings
out oh sure but i did all my tests and
so that's
jesus well it's because you don't have
any tasks because you're
[ __ ] eating come on come on i think
that's it i think that's it cool okay
good luck
all right have fun goodbye everybody all
right
again remember what christmas ever
oh no she's still in there she's still
in there that's right i keep thinking
it's trevor because of the color
my brain is dumb
[Laughter]
oh i [ __ ] knew it
i didn't deserve to be right about that
one by any stretch of the word i did not
[ __ ] deserve that
okay
[Music]
buddy oh it's the other way no no surely
not
this seems wrong what's happening
why what [ __ ] brian
okay okay is it not okay i guess i am
draining this
no what the [ __ ] what are you
doing you weird wheel
okay helping them complete they task
cause brian is dead
that's the vengeance that i really cared
about even though shelby killed me
i just could have sworn that like i
don't know i don't know
it's just a weird task okay
gonna go do my tasks hope that we
win
yeah i still have a bunch left
so here's the deal we have
we're kind of in trouble if there's
still two killers left i don't know yes
so there is there is not brian one
hundred percent i saw okay
okay i think i think i trust ethan's
word on this now yeah
yeah on your birthday that ass a hundred
percent on my birthday dead ass i'm on
cams right now because i'm completely
done with my tasks
so this round in the previous round i've
i've been on cams because i'm sorry why
would he put sus on
on amber when he died either he's trying
to goof us or it's
not it's not amber and it's shovel or
eddie it's not me
i watched eddie watching ethan on kids
unless brian's an idiot it's not amber
because why would he
call the other imposter yeah that almost
can clear her
like this if that yes just as a play
like he threw
us on her to make us clear her after
possibly
but also maybe something somebody who's
guilty would say
i'm just saying that's a play i'm not
saying she sucks because i haven't seen
her probably actually the whole game
this one is really tough because
i am not really suss of anybody i do it
is really tough it's the only thing i
saw that was weird
and this is just the thing that i say
every game you went through specimen
but didn't have a task in there anyone
who goes through there looks is looking
for a body to kill
i had i had asked a different
contamination above it
what testimony did you go through the
office i didn't
i didn't wait hold up what tasks did you
have in determination because i stood
there and i watched you and you did
nothing you just stood there looking
uh i i did wires and then i had wires it
was wires
wait but i saw you hanging around that
uh i don't know where it is on cams
ethan where's the [ __ ] like computer
that's right next to the wires i saw
chris standing at the computer and not
the one
that was that was in comms that was me
checking vitals and no one was dying
okay that makes sense to stand there for
a while [ __ ] okay [ __ ]
i am ethan chris i'm not gonna lie to
you i'm a little
shovel and amber going after me for no
reason is interesting it's i feel like
it might be
i only said because you went through
specimen you went from the office to go
back
to christ it's a weird route that's a
birthday throw if you vote for me
straight up
i might be it might be a birthday party
you're sure you go to one
notice the shovel vote boys and girls
okay okay okay
okay
there we go that makes more sense i look
like it was cut off on my chin okay
other tasks mine i would do my best for
you everyone
we just do that one that's that and then
we do this
[Music]
it could legitimately be b i don't know
no surely there's one too many
okay yeah am i still doing toss too
[ __ ] yeah who was it yes
it was me was it amber
brian i was so [ __ ] happy when i saw
you on camera
i i didn't know that cams could see into
that room because i i figured because
they were on the other hand
oh my god daniel craig's back
i thrust myself upon him falling the
entire round oh my god
i i will say i was sitting there as a
ghost and
mock basically committed suicide like
intentionally was like
kill me brian take me and it happened
it was some tasty baby nines out over
here dude
uh who are we streaming on amazon prime
waiting for
[Music]
sorry that was good southern general
that was a really good play shelby like
almost nobody was supposed to be the
whole time
only till then yeah only until the
moment he killed one person and got back
i know i was trying to slow play and i
was like
he's doing all the heavy lifting yeah
look i gotta help
don't sass me go skills so the reason
that i don't finish my tasks every time
is because i played so many games where
the settings are so different and often
we will finish the game
um before you even need to do all the
tasks
so like a lot of the times it's
pointless but i guess with the settings
we have for this particular game that
you do need to do them
um but often yeah we like i'd say like
this is one of the
very few times i've played this game
where um we need to do tasks at all
because usually it's the problems are
solved
before the tasks doing
please somebody help me
here we go okay
yeah if if if
what was that strange baby you just did
ethan is anybody dead no
okay maybe it's fine okay
i'm gonna go to the office i feel like
i'm about to get murdered
i love a good swipe weapons
it's too quiet it's too quiet hang on i
could i could go check vitals
just see was see if anybody's dead
aren't trevor is dead okay well
i guess that's a thing that i can note
but i don't think i've seen trevor
anywhere you know
like i could have write koto called a
meeting but it's not enough i feel like
that would be a waste of an emergency
meeting
to be like trevor is dead ah there he is
hello hello okay i found a body
in what up lower left is that o2
yes okay yeah so i'm in o2 the only
other person i saw was mark
who wandered in after me after i opened
one of those like shut
doors i would like to inform you that
this happened a little while ago because
i checked on vitals and made the
decision
not to report trevor because i was like
well it's a waste of a report on the
first round if nobody's gonna know where
anyone was
but it was a little while information uh
chris hold up uh you went into
determination with ethan now ethan is
dead
what do you have to say for yourself oh
i
did he did yeah ethan wasn't dead when i
checked so
ethan died recently he just died just
now
that was chris i don't know about that i
was waiting for
med babe and yeah you saw that you were
doing yours i was waiting on you
yeah then you walked down to sneak in
town you followed uh birth
and then uh now he's dead very
suspicious this is like enough
it does not mean that's not
christmas it's not a good defense chris
you got any better defense for us but
i mean i walked by him but i didn't kill
him so i don't know that's weird
um that was good
people dropped it did you go into d-com
topper box
i was going downstairs around uh
investment room oh
that's a death trap yeah trevor trevor
definitely died
earlier ethan just died for sure so i
think that is probably
just did you see it like happen on
vitals or you checked vitals and you saw
trevor was dead yeah i checked vitals i
was just like let me just go check
mock was also in that area at the time
um
yeah i checked it trevor was dead uh
ethan was not and that had to have been
like
like 15 seconds before you found the
body how long ago did you guys go into
dcom together
was that recent too he wasn't in dcom
with
[Music]
it could have been a um like electrical
kill or whatever like where it's like
dark we can
cast dust i didn't see it
i should do that more often gives you a
real idea of
of the situation assuming we were right
again who [ __ ] knows that's the
problem
okay cool ah
um i need to go in this way
okay okay brian brian brian
okay you if you kill me now it would be
a bad idea is all i'm saying
unless you're both motorists you've been
sighted brian that would have been a
shitty call
okay brian what are you doing
it surely it's not him again i'm just
i'm so scared of
being murdered by by brian okay okay
okay okay
brian please don't kill me please just
if
just nobody could kill me actually that
would be [ __ ] tight
yeah he leaves okay
somebody got it
weapons is usually kind of safe you're
generally pretty alone in
the old weapons
smashing through toss out here man hulk
brian's not a killer
not sure great
hmm bloody did you not see that body
brian you saw it right i didn't
to the right um who is it mark's body
just right uh brian where is that just
like center top a center like right
below for a spawn
who was around it uh i was in electrical
turning on
lights and then i got locked in there
and then i had to do another door to get
back out and i saw it and ran over
to report he just died like
i can i can i can confirm that brian was
in that area because i was terrified of
brian phenomenal ryan
i was i don't think brian did anything
yeah i don't think brian did anything
i was walking above from that direction
because of uh the uh key
one before and so i walked down i was
checking who was at the door
it opened up i walked with bloody and
brian bloody clearly just didn't see the
body
um and me and brian walked up to it is
there event there
i i did see bloody uh running around o2
and
uh whatever upper left is security area
yeah that was yeah that was uh i had a
task there wires
and then i went to the right side
because i have one last task
and i was locked with you there yeah no
no one was
none of uh us were out in sort of the
center also
amber pallade was also i think i saw you
in the left also
i did yeah she was in o2 with yeah so
very scared
so people that we don't have locked in
lower left right now uh
what eddie and bloody
well no i was with them yeah like with
brian as well i wasn't locked in it but
um
i was on vitals and i saw him die and
then i went to look for him but you
reported it right after so he
he was very fresh body you found that
brian walked with me too and bloody was
there as well
okay so they didn't ever see me kill if
he just did it or if he just died
that is true oh
this isn't good guys this is not good
it's the mattress
says what's the the math is not on our
side
[ __ ] i think we got chris but i don't
know i think so
i think we got chris also but chris
didn't really having a
defense at all no no i think we're good
no he's just like wow that was quick
yeah yeah yeah electrical
i really don't know like i feel like
even though i
you know said it i feel like brian had
opportunity to kill me
i don't think it's brian um
i think he also asks more questions when
he's imposter is what i'm noticing
to like throw off the scent maybe and
right now
your boy's just like communicating
fairly is what's happening
you know
it just feels huge not many tasks left
fam
not many tasks left
let's do this leave the footwork yes yes
mark should only be allowed to talk when
he's dead
oh i saw someone uh complaining that i
keep streaming this game um
it is because it does really well on
streams people um
really like watching it i guess like it
just does really well
i'm very engaged um oh it's my task i
should just go
well now i can do it faster now i can do
it faster
um so that's a bummer i didn't know it
was [ __ ] eddie
yeah jeez yes
i just i went to go do my last
terrorists got [ __ ] murdered by eddie
and then was like well
chris what was i supposed
since not everyone's on beta when i'm
imposter when i call um
electrical you guys get imposter vision
instead of it going dark
oh so should we all swap them people are
i'll wait till everyone's on their steam
can get them i'll be right back
amber you son of a [ __ ] chris i didn't
even see you kill
i just knew that you two went in there
and i was like oh
wait so who was it it was it was it was
crazy
yeah okay okay so we're all switching to
beta real quick
data right click among us in your
library properties yeah click properties
then go to betas then select the baby
you'd like to opt into public beta
check it out it's only four point four
meg all your little cuties yeah
and you're gonna get it
all right all right it takes it's a
quick uh
all right i'm going to change the map
too to the uh to the other one
oh the name auger is gamer very pogers
dude
dude i love it
yeah i actually got to go pee quick also
so yes same same
good luck uh i put the uh i put the
code in chat
i accidentally put so what's the last
map the skeletons
either i want to pull my map no
skeletons skelet's the first one
so then it is a
mirror hq yes
yes yes yes
yeah i like it right
okay even people who are really good at
this uh game
on that map that one that we're doing
now
kind of like yeah because it's so many
dead ends it's kind of weird
yeah so i like that yeah
bloody how are you today i'm good
thank you for asking how are you
i am good i'm having a fun birthday
what have you been up to
uh 24 is crazy dude i'm
well i'm really excited i'm one year
away from being able to rent a car
normally
wait you can't rent a car until you're
25 what
there's uh there's like different fees
and stuff if you're under 25 there's
they charge fees anyone here 30 in their
30s
no oh yeah i'm in my 30s
oh baby yeah oh yeah
brian might be the oldest one here
yes lovey brian i think he is i think
he's 32. wait who is
i think brian bryan is yeah i think so
really i think he was born in 87
no then he's not
i'm sorry
hello i think he was born in 87
wait brian what year were you born are
you 32 87
oh i'm i'm uh i'm younger than chris
whatever chris is like take a couple
years off that
got it got it great confirmed what year
were you born
uh 85 when the uh the nintendo
i think was released right you're my
favorite person you are
older than me yes wait brian i thought
you were 32. i'm back
uh i could be if you want me to be yeah
right
with ethan being a month older than me i
think i'm the youngest here and i
definitely don't look like the youngest
here
well because i look like my uncle eddie
dude i look like everybody's uncle
you look like my hot uncle eddie thanks
man
weird that you'd say that about your
uncle but thank you
a handsome guy um i'm [ __ ] weird
you're the youngest here but wait hold
on trevor
you're march 18th 1997
24 years young oh trevor you're younger
wait wait nine
years you're not you're not 24 yet
you're 23.
wait am i yeah
[Applause]
trevor wait did you not did you think
you were 24. i i mean
bloody i'm always having a midlife
that's really funny
you can turn on the passport
i play video games for a living i'm in
my 30s uh
uh so task bar updates uh
never meetings meetings you want to turn
on anonymous voting
sure that's kind of funny oh that's the
thing
so not asking who somebody voted for if
they voted right
i mean we could also they could just lie
if you want to say yeah that's true
that's true
[ __ ] that's kind of fun i love lying
dude let's play come on
yeah you heard of this game called the
whole game the best have you heard of
this game called
uh mungus nice yeah twitch prizes
uh thank you i didn't mean it
it was terrible and you should feel bad
i literally don't know this map
okay i do have to do this oh then
the other one i don't have to do there's
like that rocket one over there but um
it takes like your whole goddamn life to
finish
all right i haven't seen this one look
at it spooky
bats uh whatever that is what is this
is this
is that supposed to be a sub kind of
fruit i feel like i should recognize
whatever that is but i don't i keep
doing my task too slow this is my
i deserve to be voted off frankly oh
yeah that's right they updated this from
people who have colorblindness which i
thought was very cool
yo what's happened here
oh i don't know my comms are
hey
okay
i've seen a fair bit of mark i feel like
he's not being very sus
okay hmm
oh no birth is dead okay i gotta stretch
immediately on his birthday bloody i
swear that kind of looks
us that we both walked up and i walked
down but i just found this body cold i
swear to you i
jumped on trevor's body and then i went
to the vending machine which one yeah
i was going so i was going to do the
task on the map that is like
on the wall uh under cafeteria to the
left and between that and something else
i don't know the map well enough
and trevor's body was dead in the
hallway right in front of wires
or whatever that that panel game is
right there um
i think i might know where ethan died
okay
where do you think i left him up by the
reactor area
oh i did reactor and then i came back
down south
did you wait up there yes
he was still up there he was in the
right room i was in the left room doing
reactor
what beverage were you getting
are you talking about me wait what yeah
bloody whatever because you said you're
you're in cafeteria you said you were
going to the vegetable thing
well i didn't even get to pick up wait
were you afk
no well that's i bloody and i walked
down
and i walked further down to do my task
so she was definitely
there at least but like bloody couldn't
have killed
trevor because we walked down there i
kept walking further down
and found his body cold in the hallway i
have a question
what's up chris okay so i walked by
trevor earlier on
um in cafeteria and amber also walked by
me and then i left them alone and
went to go do calm so cause for real
chris that body is cold as [ __ ] like
nobody's talking
so amber so what's up what do you mean
what's up i just told you
wait wait wait the only way in here was
when i left i saw bloody she was
standing at the um
uh the vending machine and i went in and
got water and i went to go back up
you don't remember seeing so i walked by
you and trevor earlier on
wait where did you be doing wires when i
went in to get some water to fill up for
the plants
and then that was it i just i still
didn't see trevor
no hey monk
what are you what were you doing but i
know the two people
probably the best oh we're all like
little grey icons that's yes
[Music]
chris liked that too much chris is now
suss because then
the we have to vote every time this is
gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] up actually
because if we don't um then
whoever is imposter can just vote people
out first round by just voting for
whoever they want
that's [ __ ] up that's [ __ ] up this
is gonna be terrible i don't like it i'm
already stressed
they have too much power and you know
what they say about one man
is that he should never have all that
power what what
this is too much of the screen very cute
though
look at me go
all right okay i was positive with my
positivity there
that i would end up dead so mark mark
clear
clear mark what oh what
that's gonna be seven nine two two
zero all right all right all right all
right all right all right all right now
ladies
yeah brian might kill me
it's hopefully not okay i'm still alive
so that's super cool
being pretty [ __ ] weird there brian
i just said brian was being pretty
[ __ ] weird there
and that can i fly through the walls the
whole way but yeah
but i still like following the parts
anyway i can't believe he done me like
that
i just said he was being weird
i have found a corpse oh no that was
some [ __ ] belongs to alana
and it's in a hallway um now everyone
ran
towards it i totally missed it i didn't
see the event at all
this one oh yeah we when we were all
through
totally didn't know it's upper left
right
chris is that where we were can you
confirm i was up there do one quick task
and then i went
right back down
do my like gas filling but i was alone
yeah i went i went down left side and
then i
looped back up because i have no idea
where i'm going
amber to me are the two that i'm saying
yeah i'm really surprised
now if i really wanted to i could have
gotten rid of him but i didn't people
why exactly
because i'm not but i died anyway
i could have been killed by bloody or
eddie during that round didn't all of us
walk up except for amber walking away
from us and then she
said whoever was behind whoever was
behind killed alana whoever the last one
coming back behind was
because that's been there a while
obviously because i went all the way
down to the
engine to fill up the gas
i feel like one of us would have spotted
somebody
i don't think
i don't i just don't wait mark what are
your thoughts
this could be a risk yeah mark what what
are your thoughts 20 second mark
doesn't add up here why didn't you say
it earlier than mine
are we are we voting amber or not here
yeah i'm sorry oh
i think that's a sus thing to say no i'm
i'm literally i
that's me i saw bloody and eddie and
those are the only two people i saw that
entire thing
you killed ethan i think you killed the
other one great great voter for me dude
[ __ ]
trevor hey
it's even her though
why did that happen i just said also do
murders
oh so why did i don't know why that
happened okay i need to do my [ __ ]
toss i'm letting everyone down by being
too slow
lab let's go
let's do it okay okay okay okay
oh yes this one
okay i didn't realize it would be that
aggressive with me you know why is it
yelling at me
big stupid crystal all right
done that just to react it then
and then there's one more i don't know
who it is is it
i really don't [ __ ] know
uh i've done my talk
all right who did it where'd you find it
chris
i found it um at the like the y
intersection coming down from o2
um i was going to the other o2 and
mark's corpse was just there um
i don't know the map enough is there a
path to walk from there like
straight from there up into the also
where do events lead in this map
i can tell everybody events go
everywhere everywhere
yeah brian oh i didn't know brian i know
it's not
you're telling me yeah i know it's not
eddie i don't okay so where was everyone
and where was the body i was in this job
tell us where in the map we were i don't
know
you're in the top um across from reactor
in the lab
right i'm in bottom right right now i'm
bottom left i was fixing the
o2 thing yeah it got fixed right like a
vending machine thing and i did that
oh you're right it would have stopped i
went to reaction so funny
yeah because i said so do mata
[Music]
even though we're about to win shelby it
was the sorting rocks and then the
crystal formation one the
reaper okay wait what all right so if i
give myself up
so can i explain i explain why you were
sus yeah
okay so first off when when we all voted
for amber you're the last person you
literally go
wait so like who are we voting for now
like reading my chat and i have bad adds
so that actually wasn't a bit well
okay oh maybe it wasn't that's
impossible and then also
but i'm voting for myself here
i'm serious about that part though like
between like a new map
and having horrible adhd i had no idea
what was going on there any time the
anonymous voting happens
it looks like it's just me voting for
the same person
i would just like to uh give a shout out
to brian saying oh
where are the vents on this map after
venting and then murdering me
did you see me no i didn't but my chat
dude okay
so yeah so what happened what happened
was i accidentally hit the vent button
and i went oh [ __ ] i wanted just some
event and i saw you take off and i was
like she's gonna go do a meeting so i
had to kill you
oh i didn't see it at all i completely
missed it
wow no idea oh my god i got busted for a
kill i didn't even do
oh no i'm sorry this map is
so small it's so weird wait wait so who
was it other than
that's why did you kill trevor i did
oh
and i was in there that whole time so i
saw bloody walk down i was like
hopefully i can pin this on bloody
and then ethan you want to keep an
anonymous on or off
it's kind of like it's even way more
than your thing with that yeah i don't
really like anonymous
yeah yeah um i'm gonna turn that off
i'm gonna go pee really fast because
bloody's beer being right now how fast
how fast you think you can do it uh i
don't know all right you ready
dyslexic
you're pissed i said time me yeah okay
when are you leaving what are you
leaving
three two one go
[Music]
all i got from that was that he was
gonna have bloody pee that's all i heard
wow nice on his birthday he's getting
older
he is do you think spence is like having
a good day do you what do you think
spencer's up to
i ain't expensive i'm getting ready for
a surprise party for ethan
no it's so sweet spencer's so smart
it's true well your jesus are too big
and i love it
he's disproportionate face just a good
boy across the board
anyway brian you [ __ ] motorola
listen it had to be done you saw me but
you didn't really no i fully didn't see
you
i had no idea also i feel like you've
been imposter
a lot i've been imposter a decent amount
which is kind of good because i need
practice because i suck at it
i feel like mom hasn't at all he's
currently definitely
he's always third imposter though that's
true
yeah he's silent or he's daniel craig
he's two modes
yeah he's an npc with uh like back
oh it was uh i really wanted a quick
eight minutes into
his hands i had to be
[Music]
a minute and five seconds that's pretty
fast that's some quick
peeing dude but i think i probably hit
it like two seconds late so we'll give
you a minute three
next time you could do it and use your
busted urine it'll be great
yes i did use my urinal why is that
cheating why is that
cheating i thought that it was broken
and it was like leaking everywhere
uh i mean it was but i just turned i
just like
turned off and on i just turned the
water
off and on and because it constantly
flushes yeah
flushes so i just turn it on it'll flush
i'll pee while it's flushing and then
i'll turn it off
oh you know pretty good stuff
yeah you're a genius i've ever had an
important question to ask
what what's your question what did i
yeah you said something about peeing at
a desk i don't know
pepper first guys please shirt yeah if
you ever want to just do it faster you
know
i get it very fast i did cheat a little
bit
because i didn't wash my hands in the
traditional way
oh it's cute
hold on i use hand sanitizer instead of
using
oh yeah no it doesn't count anything
watch your [ __ ] hands
first dude one percent
piss on you dude you literally did not
wash the fecal matter off of yourself
you roasted
[Laughter]
no that's disgusting dude okay i have a
launchpad task
[Music]
okay holy [ __ ]
bro that wow you just waited till
everyone left and then i got [ __ ]
spanked
oh my gosh god damn
that is the fastest that's ever happened
so like what do i do now
i could eat i have food oh i can't do
this fulani
dummy helpful you can't even do
[ __ ] up pretty upset about it what
what what do you go
thank you that one
[Music]
crystals bro just such a pain in the ass
to make
uh oh
all right wow somebody's putting in
three dead bodies
oh my god whoa whoa okay that one was a
busy boy
all right the reason i self-reported was
because i went up
into admin and i saw amber's body there
and i went oh [ __ ]
self-reported he was joking yeah
yeah and so i self-reported and i found
amber's body
i saw something weird but i think it's
just because he doesn't know it's not
very well but brian why were you not
opening the door
i forgot you literally have to hit that
little tiny button
thing also trevor was standing next to
me and i was like why isn't he opening
the door because i had an electric panel
right next to it
wait ethan where did you go when the
reactor went up totally not even
it's not that big to be honest i didn't
go to reactor because i was like other
people will take care of it and all of
my tasks are up here
uh i went to the room off of the
cafeteria where the
like plant watering bucket is what is
that called
whatever that's called the watering can
yeah thank you
and then i went up and then i went up to
admin it's totally okay was anybody else
in that direction or was everybody
[Applause]
that's a win you got three kills
so sad what the [ __ ] happened yeah i
don't know
you win we are winning yeah dude
that's sucks we're a serial killer oh
that's such a bummer dude
i put a new
just to give everybody else a time frame
i'm probably gonna stop playing among us
around
six ish my time which is about an hour
yeah you got it
after six buddy you can eat some cake
i'm gonna poop
poop my pants you're in cake who's
coming over i'm [ __ ]
disgusting i'm gonna i'm gonna pants
and then i'm gonna get banned nice dude
yeah that is tos as long as you admit it
but you know keep it secret that's
that's what it is
is that as long as i admit to pooping my
pants then then it's the u.s
because you did it cool cool cool
i would love an i poop my pants apology
video
like
[Laughter]
that would be great yo this code is like
[Laughter]
yeah true true um we are missing
that would be a hell of a way to go if
you guys just get banned on the last day
that'd be great because you pooped your
yeah that would that would be wise
no i don't think you two would ban for a
poop of the pants
it would have to be we poop
[Music]
i don't know what's going on single
pantaloon
two i mean boy is the one what happened
uh it we all got dq'd amber i hope you
guys can't hear me eating you're going
to be quiet new code in the chat
i'm saying that to you chad brian why
did you leave the game brian
come back hmm he left huh yeah
it's brian just crashing in trouble if
you guys remember what i was
troubleshooting i think
yeah that was so good was it my
australian ping
yeah it was probably you is brian on the
discord now too
uh yeah i think he just said that
internet was being weird
oh okay wait did brian [ __ ] his pants
yeah i've never had fun dip and now i'm
very intrigued
it was one of my favorite candies when i
was younger but trevor you can't get it
to me
one because you're far away two coved
safety [ __ ] i'm not gonna lick
it yeah you trying to
[Music]
it's just a little bit of droplets
question what is fun dip
then it's a a stick of sugar a stick of
very
hard sugar you choose pretty much like
sweet
[Music]
is
okay uh good luck have fun everything
one one more
i'll grab my cheese on myself it's
delicious
oh i've been so busy lately that i have
not been eating well um
the mac and cheese is you know it's not
gonna be that bad it's all right do you
think that i'll die again here because i
don't want to [ __ ] have that happen
again right here last time you know
um but yeah i eat so badly when i'm busy
and i have been
but on some stuff i'm pretty excited
about there's a thing that i said on the
stream yesterday that i should be able
to announce pretty soon
this is a uh it'll be like a one-off
live show
put a lot of production value into and
stuff that uh
hopefully we pull it together it's been
difficult
all right is everybody alive yep okay
cool nobody is dead yet
okay okay
okay but why is this
mark's dead again amber did you see
something on cams or something
hello where was he oh my god i gotta be
uh
somebody invented and they have a
hamster i don't know who it was
oh he's about to be [ __ ] killed is
that bloody bloody do you have a hamster
nope who has hamsters
so i am a little guy i have a little guy
trevor you have a little guy right i do
i do have a little guy he's eddie what
do you have
my little channel yeah what do you have
eddie i just said i have a little guy as
well
i do not have a little boy i mean
i don't have a pet i have no pet uh
amber what do you have
nothing i don't have anything i'm almost
positive it's bloody
it's brian i do not have any i don't
have a i do not have a little guy
because i'm a cheapskate
no brian doesn't have to do you have a
do you have a hamster you guys haven't
seen what your pet even is
i don't have one it's a little guy oh
that was such a quick no i think from my
memory
from my mimi from my memory
has a hamster but we don't vote and we
just get them next time you can't lie
about this because if
if she's lying then we immediately know
yeah i'm not one
also and this is impossible terrible
idea killing mark first because he
filibusts for so long i know
[Laughter]
mark would be really crazy imposters
he could watch you kill someone and be
like i was doing my test
down at the store let me tell you about
them for roughly 90 seconds
shared a picture of iced tea we all used
to have hamsters all right but i've got
my eye on whoever's got a hamster
yeah i'm sorry i'm hitting that button
yeah
part of the one with the hamsters yeah
brian and i out here slumming it we
can't afford [ __ ] hamsters you guys
rich out here
i got no hamster gang let's go
okay
cool let's do it
what the [ __ ] is this
what else do i have to do
wait so it's what the [ __ ] eddie
what are you what the [ __ ] was that
what was that what is wrong with you
eddie dude
why did you do that you idiot i think
you might have
gone
[Music]
so i was on the balcony i was on the
balcony doing the weather task and then
i walked up and then uh eddie
committed a murder
you're the one sorry i'm so sorry that i
wasn't muted
chris oh that's okay i i expected you
guys to see it immediately chris you
didn't spoil anything
i didn't say anything that round because
i knew i could get a kill
so um yeah i don't know [ __ ] it it's uh
trevor's my boy he's the other imposter
trust my word guys
um all right i'll see you guys
i don't know guys also when you guys
said little guy i genuinely thought you
were just saying a cute way for a
hamster so i didn't think i was lying
there
i thought you were pretending you had
your little guy hamsters
[Laughter]
all right i still have to do this
[ __ ] task
i
right in the middle of the action i just
don't know why he did it you could have
like you were [ __ ] nice it's true we
probably would have just reported them
because everyone was standing around
there waiting right
i'm gonna go up the top and go up the
top
okay don't kill me chris aha that's
right it's this one
one seven six four eight
and then this boy each this one is quick
cool okay o2 a greenhouse rather
oh get out of here
i would like to ask the americans among
us
um the pumpkins not rot over time you
know
oh what five eight five five three
[ __ ] got y'all um because i was
talking to some of the
fun house crew about this yesterday and
um
it's literally just on the corner
but they make jokes in response to
everything like if you if you're doing
your comp and palming
did i say pumpkin pathing
am i okay like what stops them from just
rotting immediately
they do rot it seems like don't they
just smell really quickly
that's sort of my thing do they take
monster run i don't know
what hey hey hey
to contaminate me baby all right
how's everyone doing i'm alive can you
explain how you just got from
up to all the way down without walking
where i did
what do you mean i think you just i
think you just invented
i saw you at the top and then i walked
down to the cafeteria
and then you came up from the bottom no
i didn't i walked there
hey a trip but i saw a lot of people in
my way what
i mean
did you drop your fun dip down event i
just wanted to wait we got two
venting accusations now do we have to
use the second one
maybe i could be wrong wait do it was
eddie not actually impossible
no no no no no eddie totally was uh so
where did you take
vent no i was just finding my fun dip
[Laughter]
amber do you see him bent or are you
just goofing no no i saw him
stand up look back look back at me and
then just stand there and i thought hmm
this is a [ __ ] oh did he use it
no no he just stood on it okay okay
we could vote bloody and then trevor
next round if we wanted to just decrease
i don't know just when it was bloody i
think okay awesome sauce
excuse me what did you say something
about awesome sauce awesome sauce
trevor because he did awesome he said
awesome sauce i might have to vote trev
on this one
are you kidding me it's a big towel
he's an awesome sauce i'm sorry that's
kind of weird this is a terrible idea
we heard two vent accusations and i
don't know the map wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait what
it's i don't think trevor did anything
what what happened
what pretty it's okay you can see
positive
fun dip i don't know what to push why
did we do that you [ __ ] dummies
i don't understand why did that happen
it was it was never trevor it was never
trevor
what the [ __ ] bro
that was that i don't know what happened
did they do it for the joke
like what
oh my gosh
this [ __ ] might kill me i don't know
for trouble
this [ __ ] might kill me
chris chris chris you got it
it's bloody we could we win
[Laughter]
eddie was not called out immediately
he would have a shot to be fair to
yeah a little bit of uh you know lagging
behind there i guess
i'm sorry i'm sorry you showed your true
ass dude
sorry trevor you were just eating your
fun dip my best
we got it no he's good because he got to
eat more
yeah exactly
[Laughter]
i was talking to chat the whole time
because i finished my test what happened
yes
oh
i accept your apology
do we want to do original map or keep
doing this one more
i'd be down to the original map for like
two more rounds yeah original
okay yeah yeah yeah oh gee map yeah this
one's awesome
i'm crying
i would love to see uh chris oh dude you
got all the candy
big league chew you got big league chew
over there trevor trevor
all right did you say some strains of
big league chew
a little grinch yo what's different
[Music]
do they still make the the big league
like roll up gum is that what they
that was what was that or was it hubba
bubba that did that one yeah
dude i love swallowing those holes
do you see those maniac kids
all right well happy birthday bye i
guess that's it for the stream
[Laughter]
swallow it hole ooh like a snake
what's the address good look have fun
[Music]
all right so for anyone in here we're
gonna stream till six
nice big stream for iffy boys birthday
okay
[Music]
uh ethan is one of my best friends and
the only person i saw on my birthday
actually
um and i love him
and you should all wish him a happy
birthday he is crank gameplays
on all of the things
okay that was risky
i was just saying really nice [ __ ] about
you ethan i was just being so
complimentary
what a sticky situation oh my god
i take it all back
they killed her after she turned them on
that's a shame
yeah that's a shame i tried
i was just saying how great he is what's
that what a shame
uh okay wait so sorry what info do you
have
i electrical no one was in the room i
think that they vented in
correct probably vented out actually
or not was it front or back
it was at the light switch she turned
them on and then died
i can't believe they made her do the
task and then slaughtered her there
they let her turn the lights on first
yeah she did one final good job
you're welcome
[Music]
do you guys just want to do soul read
and vote someone off the killer just
wanted something
climb check was there anyone possibly or
security [ __ ] your boxer confirm no
invented from there
nope no okay well
i think we don't know anything then okay
great um cool
it's only once that's about it only one
day so close to spotting him
mark
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
wait that's very suspicious normally you
would ramble
on that is pretty weird okay okay okay
give me a chance
i'm just gonna eat my food that's good
but then i keep being the last one to do
toast okay
[ __ ] sake
um everything that i said about ethan
earlier
is a lie he is very rude
and um manipulates people
into thinking he's a very good boy and
close friends with you
before he kills you in cold blood and
then on the stream
is all so what information do we have
even though he knows he [ __ ] murdered
me
i really thought he was gonna be fine i
was just like yeah just two bros
going to it was such a risk too the
speed
at which he did that was i'm having a
lot of feelings right now having to deal
with this
is basically what's happening
that one seemed too fast you'd be
inconsistent son of a [ __ ]
down to shields you want us to remove
the happy birthday tweets
yes yes yes so everyone who tweeted at
crank game plays and said happy birthday
can you maybe instead tweet at him don't
say happy birthday
say say um
all right i think i saw unhappy birthday
do that
okay all right what's up okay i just
stumbled across a body
with chris yeah so i think oh
wait wait we can literally we can
literally find out where everyone is
brian you were with me eddie where were
you yep just now i was in the right side
of the map i think i
ended up maybe around shield all i need
to know shovel where were you
okay i'm in storage but i think it's
brian
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
there's no i believe you uh trevor where
were you wait you believe me
don't mind me okay um ethan
yes i was in the hallway uh in between
like comms and weapons
is that when you wanted someone ethan
how did you catch him
so disappointed wait chris i'm confused
did you believe
shelby about brian i think it's yeah
white i think you're slammed
on him i saw i saw it just saying
i saw a dark grey character kill in
front of me and i'm pretty sure it was
ethan dude
oh okay the only reason i said brian was
because i watched
him and it was going with him standing
there for a very long time i did not
because he was
ethan at all no okay
all right you can you can vote i
literally walked
hold on chris were you with anybody yeah
with brian
right behind you yeah yeah i literally
walked up to the body at the same time
oh okay okay sorry i was just trying to
figure out what brian
wait so shelby why do you say that you
think it's brian
he was doing topo too but he wasn't
doing it he was the only one standing
there
because i was literally just typing in
the numbers i'm sorry
for a long time kind of letting it run i
wasn't saying it was could be confusing
something they are
they go like not in order that's
confusing right i can believe that but
then
why are they not voting for oh okay
brian but
can you confirm that christopher
wait how come when trevor comes in with
like wait really why
it's not suss but when i do it it's us
yeah we actually got it
too
okay now well we have other tasks
do an electrical task which is what i
was trying to do when he then murdered
me
i'll be really like that the update is
good for colorblind people that's dope
it's good stuff
good video game work can't do [ __ ] about
lights
oh eddie that was swift dude
uh oh no eddie you should leave you have
an alibi for
being in this direction
chris find the body chris chris find it
come on come on it's right there but why
did you
[ __ ] i gotta do tasks i know but i just
that was that was spicy [ __ ]
there there you go there you go
hello oh my god yo
what's up so so i have i have a um i
have a
yeah i have a theory okay okay
i found this body in storage the only
person i think it could potentially be
is eddie because he was the last person
i saw walking away from it
i saw brian walking in that direction
beforehand
i passed brian in that hallway before
that chris well he was stuck in he was
he was stuck in electrical though yeah
chris and i were on opposite sides of
the door when it locked in
electrical okay then i don't know
because i was
i was walking that way but i was in
reactor for forever
like a
ethan so i think we're good i got ethan
yeah
sure and it was ethan eddie or brian
well do you want to be like a good old
soul read who do you think brian or
eddie what are you guys
a good soul i believe you but i think
it's you
i said we go for eddie maybe or brian i
don't know i don't [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i saw brian sticking around in that
direction that's all i saw
i was in a left hand doing wires and
then ran upper left to finish the little
crystal turning thing come on
he did go left because i passed him
there is a chance dude i don't have
anything interesting to say
eddie count to 10. there's a chance that
eddie walked by
brian while he well he just finished a
kill and then brian went up to
electrical and then got stuck in there
quote unquote
[Music]
very interesting very interesting okay
what's the other theory against eddie
though because now i feel like there's
bias
we don't have to vote here actually no i
think we should focus and then we should
we call another meeting right and we
vote
it's trevor trevor here's the video
trevor here's the deal we call a meeting
and um we get it i'm voting for brian
oh no no i didn't read it it could be
ah chris were you the other one no
you were eddie voted for himself wait
did you wrote for myself [ __ ] i went to
vote
i'm so
that was [ __ ] up that was dead to me
but i'm dead
that that was dirty [ __ ] man okay i
really need to do my tasks alana you
gotta you gotta i know you're enjoying
the spectacle but you have wires and
thing to do
okay woman just get your job done you
know
you don't let the team down
oh my god i was running i'm voting
i think it's trevor man
sorry i'll hear you out trevor's been
trying to bribe us with candy this
entire night
come on dude don't you have to see me
too
you could vote me but what if you voted
trevor think about that
well that's not it i'm on candy
well you tried eddie you're pretty close
man
yeah dude well can i ask ethan why did
you say you can vote me this first time
oh my god because i'm a [ __ ]
and you're like you can yeah you guys
you can vote me i'm like you're leaving
me out here with everybody else i'm
sorry anyone else do i see amber for
half the [ __ ] map
listen man i don't know it's mine
i'm very sorry the way it's worked
yeah it's okay because i'm gonna milk
this next one
i was saying the nicest stuff about you
and then you [ __ ] murdered me i was
like everyone go wish ethan a happy
birthday on twitter and then you [ __ ]
killed me and i was like regret
well you know what now take it back i
told them to take it back i told them to
take it yeah i have a question
why why am i always being sussed
you're just like
all it takes is shelby going i i'm
suspending brian and i go and she goes
uh because i kind of saw you in an area
that was sort of near a body
and then everyone goes yeah that's good
i just said you were suspicious
i hate this game this game is trash i
don't like playing it i never want to
play it ever again in my life
if i just stick with my imposter buddy
maybe that will help
we could do things together
you know and then one of us could be
cleared maybe if we just [ __ ] hang
out
and i make that strat and i'll just i'll
just stand over this one
or here maybe i'm trying to hang out
with you shelby
[ __ ]
oh god okay
i don't know what i'm just i'm stressed
man i'm [ __ ] stressing out
i should report that
all right all right
hang on let me pull up a map real quick
oh my god here he goes
leaf two leaf three leaves
uh four leaves is this one the scale
five
leaves hang on hang on i have
information i'm just trying to pull up
the map to make sure i'm right okay okay
so
i was in communications chris was in
communications
right before me i walk out of
communications and all i see is brian's
dead body
brian i noted wait
guys i don't know
i think it's pretty legit well lana
you're saying you're thinking that i'm
obsessed because i
didn't even see that body you're the
only person that i saw in that area
and then i walk out of that room and a
body is dead right outside the doorway
i'm not saying that you did it but
that's i'm saying that's all i saw
it's not me i i feel like i don't really
sound like it's convincing but it's not
me
i was uh in i was doing i think one
task in communications i went to storage
who's laughing who's gaming for me i'm
giggling because the first thing that
you said was
that's so weird
[Laughter]
yo here's the deal here's straight up
it's not me um
but like obviously it looks shitty you
could let me do my task and then we'll
win
the leaves are just turning a lovely
shade of brown it must be fall
nice so blood away from home for so long
haven't seen terra firma get getting
space madness
i mean it's very poetic and i don't want
to stop we're all killers but did anyone
see anyone else walking between storage
and shields
um because that's all we can identify i
always tap right
past mark so i can at least say it's not
him this time i'm gonna think it's mario
because he hasn't gotten it do you i
mean i guess it could be but i don't
know
i think he was coming from the vote back
to the league
so i don't think mark did this song
about space madness what if we all have
[Music]
is this a who killed markiplier did you
guys hear kristen he's keeping my eye on
his eye on me he didn't see me the whole
round what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
interesting chris all right we played
that okay
probably didn't do enough but you know
it was all right you know
i could have done some better work in
there but
uh
it do be what it do be sometimes damn it
shelby damn it okay i it i don't like
being in
in electrical and killing because the
only way really out is event and
it's just too boxed in you know
i have nothing to do
i haven't found anyone to murder yet
nobody's seen me
doesn't matter it doesn't
that would have been a nice place to
commit a crime if somebody were in there
but alas they were not
i can wait i could just i just wait
until someone walks in and see what
happens
four seven two seven one
okay
uh that they all came for it you know
[ __ ] i hate it so much
[ __ ] i tried to press it and i missed it
that would have been a good kill
i just straight up missed the button
that's happened to me more than once
with this stupid [ __ ] game too you
know
okay my neighbors just decided just
right now to play very loud music huh
sometimes you just miss the button you
know sometimes you just [ __ ] miss it
so
all right i found a body mark you were
chasing me that whole time and you just
standing there when we were in nav
why were you just standing there that
was weird because i was watching you
i liked the way you moved and it seemed
like you did tasks
but also on top of that i too
had the task of navigation hmm which one
the shippy dotted liney one there's also
a task i'm all right it's the cafeteria
and mark was just standing at a table
so i think maybe mark also
also i'm a little suss of alana
because alana was the one on o2 and
last second when we all went over there
it finally happened
can i say you guys just say i tried to
throw brian out for that and i was wrong
wait but shelby you were walking to the
other room assuming you walked in and
saw alana there right
she was going towards the o2 when i
walked in yeah no i
i no no no i wasn't i wasn't i think
i just got there basically just before
you guys had done it like there was this
is not there's no part of this is
like wait so why would she go to toppo
too did you see alana in there shelby
she was in admin i don't
i was walking no no shelby and i passed
in like a hallway
no it was right outside we weren't even
is it outside yeah that could just be my
thing and then
i just did i did the toss you guys
walked in pretty soon after me
i wouldn't shoot on the o2 thing only
because i got that wrong
before you're voting her out yet but
okay just to be successful
why'd you vote so fast yeah i looked up
because i was speeding on this
was following me around a lot and mark
didn't seem like he was doing tasks
and there was a lot of times where it
would have been a good opportunity to
kill me but then at the last second
somebody else walked in
and that i feel it makes me
uncomfortable and also mark hasn't been
not either now listen chris's body
was over in reactor and mark was chasing
me and i reported it as fast as i could
because i was afraid of being killed by
the man
with long hair look okay
there are many men with longer hair than
i but you
[Music]
that was close i i almost accidentally
[ __ ] voted for eddie there too it
clicked eddie and i was like
we need to do too much murder they're
going to finish their [ __ ] toss we
have to kill so many people
this is not this is not going well this
is not going to be a good time
for us i don't think so the the tiber is
very long but i really just need to
[ __ ] murder someone
and they're already suss with me and
they should be uh so we can just [ __ ]
just just do it like you know
i need to just [ __ ] kill someone and
then just kill eddie
just killed ethan right in front of me
while giving everyone a speech about how
it was like the sauce of you anyway a
lot and just [ __ ] kill someone you
know
so i just killed lethal um it was it was
sort of a payback for the last round if
i'm being honest
okay i'm voting a lot on my
birthday
[Applause]
it cannot be done they have too many
tasks that they can finish i was like
we're [ __ ] there's no way we can win
this
other so you gotta [ __ ] kill
everybody
uh mark if you could kill more people um
that would be really helpful i'm looking
at
i could have blamed eddie there but
it there's no way
ah so we'll just stop do some sabotage
did you see what happens get up
that's about it she's gonna have a tough
time
i've won as imposter today sometimes
you just gotta take a risk why did he
double back their way wonder they
already suss with me it's fine you know
we
did we get to do a bad impostor game
it's fine it's fine
our guys just there's no way they're
gonna [ __ ] finish all this [ __ ]
shelby your behavior is pretty weird
though
okay okay is anyone coming
oh that was actually oh i don't think
anyone saw you
why did you walk away what
i think it might be shovel no can i say
what i just saw
yeah i was on cam's amber walked up to
the body and then walked
want nothing to do with it
i saw her i turned right back around oh
my god
that's very interesting did you walk up
on a cold body yeah that was straight
oh well so i saw shovel come down going
to cams and then i went up and then she
started following me
and then i found because they saw the
body on the camera
and then i saw the body in your med
that's a good excuse
so i mean i don't know for sure that
it's amber but she did
with you everything you did walk away
from the body when you saw it
look
[Laughter]
you know because i had one task left
it's just what
i don't like
yeah i voted it's not me though
why did she do that she just did not
want to touch that body
it was so weird oh my god we're about to
be in the game
oh my god i don't know i don't oh my
goodness
i just had to say that that happened i'm
sorry
i shouldn't have thrown the motor to be
fair i didn't know that he would turn
around
but i didn't expect that to be a [ __ ]
part of it holy [ __ ] i would have
thought she was sauce too she walked
into the body and then she walked away
wait did i not do that sabotage right no
i did that was really strange
sometimes you just see some bizarre [ __ ]
anybody anybody okay trevor
are you trying to die come on shuffle
where are you
where are you you don't got that much
work to do
i'm sorry for what i did it's we were
too slow on the first [ __ ] round
that's just you know that's my beef what
are you guys hanging out for okay
all right so what are we doing here
i am pretty much 100 positive it's not
mark
because we were doing even the same task
at some point i've been alone with him a
ton during this game
thank you um trevor and shelby
trevor you came back and clicked the
button shelby where did you go during
any of that i went back onto cameras but
then comms never got fixed so i started
going
towards comms i'm outside electricity
now interesting training
because i wanted to call emergency
because i think it might be you shovel
but it might be mark i don't know
mark there is no way that it's me and
i'll
tell you why you gotta be [ __ ] quick
buddy
because i didn't kill anybody there you
go
i mean okay but you were with him the
last round but no one died this round
anyway
yeah i'm saying even before we were
electrical alone for a long time
downloading we're both an admin alone
uploading
like i didn't feel like this was ever
going to work if it is then it's a
really careful game but also
i did sabotage that around this release
i was the only seventh grader i'm not
ever okay guys i want to note that
trevor's no excuse feel
just accused all three of us at one
point and trevor found the last body
yeah so i can't yeah i didn't know
anything
yeah i believe you just trevor
i think it might be shelby or you're
manipulating me and
tr uh tugging at my heart i don't know
how to administer i can't afford to vote
wrong
i might i'm not saying this if i could
say a thing i have seen eddie
i've seen you around mm-hmm
the ones that i have not been i didn't
expect this for how to go this
shovel and trevor right the two of those
i only saw trevor towards the end
and he hit the emergency button better
to play it without killing someone as
opposed to calling a meeting
right or isn't that the smart play
i'm gonna punch you in your achilles
heel buddy you don't vote
trevor
all right uh i have to pee really bad
and then one last game
yeah sounds
good my bad tell me i just thought they
were [ __ ] when you accused me
sorry forever about it mark wasn't with
you the whole time you were really
intelligent there
but i'm not smart enough to make that
call
[Laughter]
oh it's trouble i will say that the most
jarring part about that round was mark
actually playing the game at the end i
know that was the most surprising part
well i i would have played the game but
i've been
dead yeah
that is true what happened with that
table earlier when you were just
standing
at one of the lunch tables i was
watching ethan he's having lunch we're
just having lunch
okay so i was making sure he wasn't
just throwing shade for slow and shade
yeah wait ethan were you one of the
imposters
or anything went away right he went to
the bathroom was yeah
it was me yeah because i walked in and
killed
killed ethan and i didn't think that
eddie would double back but
he did well that's the thing is i was i
was curious because mark was up there i
was like okay well somebody's walking in
so i'm gonna find a dead body somewhere
and i walked into that but especially
yeah like ethan was i was really sassy
ethan because he was accusing mark the
whole time for pretty much nothing other
than just kind of walking it
[Laughter]
and obviously i was doing my tasks at
the same time it was just happened to be
right he was doing it damn it
well i i'm sorry you did a great job
shelby all things considered i really
tried too it was incredible
i was so prepped for like a gaslight
fight when you when i reported the body
you killed in the original [ __ ]
i did it and i was like thank god i had
this like
this like last game
let's go why couldn't i just get a last
game where i didn't have to do this
you know i don't want to do it anymore
is the problem
i would prefer to do i have to do it
[ __ ] i was gonna
kill him i was really gonna kill him but
there was like three people around i was
like
just murder him because i hate being
imposterinated too much sometimes it's
just too much
how is trevor's imposter i actually
don't know
that's the thing oh
i just saw trevor i just saw i just saw
trevor kill
uh bloody that was are you kidding me
there's like four people there
can confirm just came off of a task
jesus christ
can confirm there were four people or
can confirm trevor
you can confirm uh there's a dead body
okay well it's just a group of people i
think it's trevor
uh i'm almost positive that it's trevor
because i think the other person that
was over there which i
think was eddie uh was doing the task
no i wasn't nav and brian was just saw
me was it amber no who you [ __ ] saw
it was a green it was a green person
amber so it was you no i just literally
did wires
huh no no that's what i mean is you were
doing wires in storage right
yeah yeah okay you were doing wires in
storage
wait so you hit the task up and the
other person was trevor and i saw a body
fall and trevor was right next to
it and i saw it happen kidding me i
voted trevor what the
[ __ ] i could be very wrong but i feel
like if ethan
was the impostor he wouldn't be throwing
accusations at two people when he thinks
it's not
early but also i don't want to throw if
it is ethan so it is also the last game
though he could have got like a chaotic
evil boy oh
this bloody body falling to the ground
what i see
is a green man and an orange man what's
happening i don't know who i don't know
i would like to ask what you think no
because because i came back up
i was going towards i was going crazy
because i was standing there and there's
something to other people i'm so
confused
okay
i don't trust anyone in that that trio
i don't really have to do anything there
but i don't feel good about it we just
wasted time
but it didn't accomplish anything i want
to throw up
it's so long
okay why don't we just go pretend to do
like the task that's like right here
you know
i should play properly but i just
my head just should i do this i
shouldn't
but no i could have but now
she'll be able to see me
we are going to do swipe tasks pretend
to do this and then we are going to kill
shelby
and then we are going to bed
where be the body all right i'm
reporting the body again i know that
makes me look
looks it's real sus but i'm not gonna
walk into admin find a body and then
walk out because that would be
not great that did get amber last time
yeah uh so i saw i saw
shelby in uh admin
okay only person i saw in admin was
chris when i was doing card swipe i went
down
into electrical where i have four
different tasks
okay that's a lot of detail um i was in
med bay i saw amber there i was just
leaving
and to walk down and i walked into
storage so i guess i walked past
admin but i definitely didn't go in
there anyways you're doing lawyers in
admin
or uh yep yeah you saw me come from
below i don't want ethan accusing me
again
i was doing the task but like it would
be a real ballsy move so i do believe
that you walked in
below and ethan you i mean you must saw
me come
like below you anyways right where did
maloney went
shields and storage shields and storage
oh i came i came here where do the admin
vents lead
shields and what else is it o2 or is
there ventino 2
uh i think it's o2 yeah
i don't know i'm not sure alana where
were you at and also chris
i was in cafeteria i just finished a
task in cafeteria and then had to go to
the other side i was
about to head to midbay i was interested
and then they went to oh too and i did
um the leaves and i could
say mark was with me dawson leaves out
into the chris is the only person that i
also saw in cafeteria
so so chris wasn't having to have a
point did anyone walk into admin like
mid game at
all no no that was late game when i
i chris uh left after me that's the only
thing i saw
after you okay so i'm concerned that
ethan has been like last game baby chaos
and that's what's happening yeah maybe
yeah
yeah i'm going to say something in the
in the last 15 seconds
i'm still voting trevor again because i
literally [ __ ] saw him
kill bloody oh my god oh my god so
that's what i'm doing because i don't
have anything else i'm just going to do
this
because i think it's funny i hate this
person just because i thought it was
funny
[Laughter]
we
yeah i thought it was us just why not
you know what i mean
uh okay well we got away with that
somehow
uh you know somehow that happened i hate
it and i would like to die
whatever i do here i think i should keep
ethan alive
is all i'm [ __ ] saying
[ __ ]
i'm not playing this game anymore i may
have had friends ask me to play it
literally tomorrow
but what if i just never [ __ ] i just
killed ethan i literally just killed
ethan
i shouldn't i didn't he was the one i
didn't want to kill why the [ __ ] did i
do that
no it's fine
okay well at least i have accountability
buddies uh but i didn't want to kill
ethan
i didn't want to do that i just hit it
too fast by reflexes you know
just too speedy sometimes uh [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude
i ruined all my own plans i'll kill you
[ __ ] jump in here i guess whatever
you know it's cool calms
oh my god
holy [ __ ] what
happened ethan was right ethan was right
it was right
and you saw him kill someone and we did
it anyway oh my god
i killed you by accident ethan i was
like keep ethan alive he's suspicious
and then you were the first person i saw
already just spam the button i was like
well i was ethan
that's my bad but i guess we won anyway
so
damn that was that was quick that was
quick good work trevor
thank you i ended up being tidy even
with the failure
good [ __ ] like i found a group at the
end and then i didn't realize like that
last kill would be the end
i wanted to do another yeah ethan i
believed you dude i'm sorry
thank you so much i appreciate it i'm
sorry
that was [ __ ] crazy man uh
my heartbeat was really fast on that one
i don't know why i was just like
i was very panicked my gosh
my gosh tidy [ __ ]
okay
i hate it though okay well
mark's had a lot of [ __ ] shots to kill
me he's never been imposter i feel like
imposter mark would be chaotic energy
that nobody's ever seen
it's not him what are you doing what are
you doing
shelby shelby
shelby
okay well that was a bit sauce
imagine my surprise
oh my god ready to go get some food
after a long day's work and i find
i just want to remind you that there is
a time limit i [ __ ] love that
it's now been up
yeah did you see anybody i saw nobody
around
when i found the body i only saw a
marker player going up from i think
uh 02 into cafeteria so i don't think he
could have done a self-report plus i
don't think he's capable
no i don't think
[Laughter]
you know have someone talk if they sound
like they're about to cry
we vote them off um i just want to ask
always ready to cry uh i just shelby
what were you doing
when you walked in the room and then you
just [ __ ] pieced out of the room and
you didn't do anything in the room
you walked into the room with me and
then you left the room we were in admin
i don't know
oh oh i actually don't know i guess i
thought i had a task in there but i
didn't
i don't remember hmm okay
i have more information if you wanted
great wonderful chris you voted quick
are you
voting voting no no no hang on what what
who are you alana
is fine yeah bloody was right at weapons
paladin was in
the cafeteria when we alana and i were
both there i went down brian was
standing by the shields bottom right
after i went there i looped back around
threw weapons two cafeteria found the
body
paladin
keep an eye keep an eye on amber then no
no i don't i mean that's the only thing
so i just i never saw but i don't trust
for some reason i think that's fair
after who each one did recent
again because he called you up for not
being able to do a self report
okay okay it's not mock
and i almost want to stick with mock
because you're not muted alana oh sorry
guys hey it's not mark though
just so everyone knows i forgot to view
the discord here we go
it's not market i almost want to stick
with bach because i know that it is dot
bach
i'm celeste shelby i'm suss of a lot of
female [ __ ]
did what did you was my read so bad you
just failed out
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] video
game [ __ ]
amber you're really on my dick
shelby probably would have killed me
there i think shelby and mark are clear
even though it was [ __ ] weird what
she did okay
i saw trouble kill and self-report there
was
my word against his i don't know why
you're laughing when he later saw you
killing self-report
instantly okay hold on wait where was it
in admin yeah i was in admin where she's
going to do my wires because i did my
wires and electrical first then i went
over to
wires and admin and he killed i don't
know how you can do wires when you're
imposter
why are you laughing i literally saw you
murder a man
self-report and blame an innocent person
such as myself
first of all the entrance of admin
anyway
shelby could have killed me i i i no i
think this is true
i'm voting trouble walking to work that
you're blaming me
he stabbed brian right in the hall like
entrance doorway of admin
and then the only thing
is that shelby and i don't mean to call
you out i've known you for a very long
time
and your your voice is a little weird
right now
well because she's still on the motor
and someone's blaming her for it i fully
think no
shelby and i have been alone in a room
for a while there uh mark you were alone
in a room with shelby
and i just walked in and oh yeah you
guys weren't electrical together
oh heck yeah actually i only said that
in the electrical i saw shelby standing
over the vent but not necessarily that
was the device
it might have been the download i saw
top right corner she was up there i
didn't want to chance i went back down
i came around palada was being a little
suspicious like creeping up on me but
didn't commit to anything
there was another body which was
christian issues okay do you know
anything about chris
where he was last chris i was just
saying chris's body
no was in the top left over there i
don't trust trevor for a second
but ethan does no mark we're good
if shovel knows if ethan knows troubles
tell
i would be willing to trust that no i
genuinely think shelby's getting played
i 100 percent believe that like shelby
looks like you want to vote
i have to fully think shelby's getting
played me out i don't care okay
are we voting trevor it's trevor
but i don't know if that actually means
anything i have no idea
he might just be playing the game now
because he's making a [ __ ] mistake
no i mean if you want a 50 50 yes i
don't care i think no i think you're
good
i don't i think it's okay pallad and
chris were in admin together why does
that matter
um so the reason i think that is
is her reaction to everything um
that was a [ __ ] who was mad
panicked about what was happening
and then trevor reacted in such a cool
way and shelby if she had when she
walked in that room it was [ __ ] weird
um but
i don't want to die though [ __ ] up
so let me do it let me son of a [ __ ] um
that was weird right she walked in said
she didn't have a task and then left
but if she were going to kill me she
could have [ __ ] killed me like it was
the behavior of someone she didn't even
remember it by the sounds of things
and now she's dead didn't think it was
shelby didn't think it was shelby
unfortunate events um i was right i
didn't see anything or anyone but i did
see shelby's thick hair but
so oh you saw it this time huh you
couldn't see mine
last time look okay wait hold on where
was it
near security so it's like right now
[ __ ] you check it out she was going to
look at kane
all your [ __ ] saying that she
was going to collect evidence well said
it zero iq
should have listened to me this is
fascinating to me because bloody passed
me right by bottom right
like around towards the end so i was
going the complete opposite direction
but far enough away that it was
justifiable alana i think you're clear
definitely
palada you were pretty pretty okay you
had opportunities to come after me you
didn't
ethan what's your justification and
where were you what's my justification
i went up i can clear bloody for the
record i can clear bloody
i think also i can clear ability how can
you clear bloody as well we were just
doing the talking together
i went into electrical uh and then i
went up into
top reactor and then i was going back
into cafeteria at the end of the game
that would put you in the right spot to
kill this person wait so mark why didn't
you
why did you clear amber though
hey wait hey i'm just saying i don't
clear amber
i clear bloody i clear bloody i don't
clear amber just because
uh she had opportunities but didn't
pursue them
i haven't seen ethan at all i haven't
seen ethan either that is the one person
i haven't seen anywhere
so here's what do you mean you haven't
seen me mark you saw me in storage
i didn't see you any storage did you see
me in storage i saw you in storage this
is
here's what we do guys we vote out ethan
right now and if it's not ethan we go
and we
uh call a meeting and example i agree i
agree
done tight work
you just you just press the button it's
just not a good idea i think you guys
should be voting so much
i think we've done this it's a little
weird guys
i feel like i got [ __ ] over here it's
my birthday and uh
yeah kind of a [ __ ] yeah let's go
oh my gosh after that kill i dipped i
was leaving ready and
she came out of nowhere and i was
slamming to click the button and he
[ __ ] killed me on my way there i was
so happy
holy [ __ ] oh
geez ethan you've been way better at
lying i'm just gonna say that yeah you
really haven't
i've gotten better at lying yeah by a
lot like you used to be like
what are you asking me for and now it's
all subtle
he's also not drinking and when he
drinks he just drops the f word every
other word
i've been drinking this entire time
brian
very good but the only reason i i
suspected you
after that is because you you earlier in
the games
every time it was you you would distract
people by immediately accusing
asking someone else where they were when
they asked you and you wouldn't answer
the question
[Music]
studying this whole time
from doing a bit as a detective to the
last two games becoming a real detective
i remember everything that happened it
was amazing
oh so good so damn good uh
guys thank you so much for coming
[Music]
tomorrow
i got you more fun dip actually oh
nice favorite
[Music]
that i have been influenced and i will
be getting fun dipped for the first time
just saying pretty good wow
i will see all of you later
thanks for coming to my big birthday
bonanza happy birthday brother
thanks for the invite happy birthday
feel good man i think i got a lot of
wins today is all i'm saying
i just i feel like i got a lot of dubs
some like some bad losses for sure but
i just think you should put some respect
on my name
that's all i'm saying